des gens voient la bascule à damas m
l'échiquier on va laisser bas qui en
grand plan est mince
ce dont on avait peur avec fab c'est une
sicilienne fou prend 17 ce qu'on a pensé
qu'ils pourraient tenter s'était dit ça
avec fabre s'est dit que ça pourrait
partir là dedans malheureusement c'est
le cas ça peut être difficile à gagner
donc ma news tu vas jouer l'annulerait
magnus qui va jouer là nul attendez je
vérifie que tout soit bien parti reste
difficile cette variante bas c'est
difficile de jouer le gardant cette
ligne bakchich qui est côté noir
c'est pas grave ça dure à gagner tant
que c'est gagnable ouais mais tu peux te
faire bien sécher il va jouer un joint
et audemars occire est ce que j'ai à
vous dire il va jouer ces 4 il va faire
les taux
ils cherchent là nul mais le truc c'est
qu'il peut la jouer pour gagner aussi
c'est terrible il peut jouer solide
essayer de contrer ces terribles et
estime qu à le prez d'accord le prêt ce
qui laisse pas les taux de marc auxi le
presse qui ne reste rien ce système est
que cinq lycées 6
soudé solide à la fois arrêts bon du
coup magnus à une fois ya une position
plus ou moins assumée trick au niveau
des pions juste les blancs le bon fou
contre le mauvais fou mais ba qui va
vouloir envoyer du f 5 à 4 et attaquer
le roi en fait c'est plutôt bien
détroit et il va pouvoir tenter va être
joué avec jeff stinco et avoir une
position un peu déséquilibré on y aurait
eu f pour le moment peut-être il va
faire j'ai six mètres le fou en g7 et
jouets pour du f5 et tête et c'est après
de faire fkt tout envoyer sur le roi
ça semble être la chance pour baky de
jouer à de jouer ce type d'attaqué il
fait f5 direct alors arrive là il n'est
pas embêté par l'idée de jouer avec ef
est clairement si à rock hill va envoyer
le pion f4 il va essayer de tout envoyer
sur le roi c'est plutôt une bonne
décision de la part des siennes je pense
malheureusement qu'il va y avoir pions
problème cinq ici
d'après 25e
on va voir
je n'étais pas un intérêt pour les
joueurs non
toutes les réflexions que tu peux donner
les joueurs les ont maintenant ils
pensent beaucoup plus de choses en fait
je pense qu'il ya eu un coût non dans
l'anus en train de réfléchir
ok
intéressant
raf qui s'est incrusté vrai
marambat qui réussit encore à prendre le
dessus dans l'ouverture
enfin le dessus pas vraiment mais réussi
à imposer un problème je pense qu'il est
censé prendre en fait j'ai joué pour les
cases blanches
mais ce qui peut l'embêter c'est qu'il
n'a pas envie de jouer une pause d'une
partie des équilibres et magnus lynch se
sent moins joué qu'hier bas on est mené
1 0 angers vélo on faut pas l'oublier un
mieux meilleur le scorer plus en or là
on est inquiet pour baky quand même
ouais non là c'est dur avec les noirs
égaliser c'est très difficile mais
l'ouverture se passe plutôt bien
en tout cas c'est bien il a il force
magnus à réfléchir
manu s'il aimerait bien faire une nulle
rapide avec les blancs mais c'est vrai
que cette idée de jouer cette structure
s'est pas fait pas forcément en faveur
des noms avant cette structure mais ça
crée un déséquilibre direct sur
l'échiquier
ça c'est intéressant il peut même jouer
avec grand roque et toutes envoyées sur
le roi plutôt bien ce qu'il fait et yann
en ce début de partie
est ce que ma qui doit absolument grille
cette partie oui il est obligé de gagner
il a les noirs mais honnêtement sur les
premiers coups ça se passe plutôt très
bien
là il va y avoir un combat il a réussi à
trouver une position où manu tu vas pas
pouvoir gérer facilement
il peut peut-être égaliser un qui sait
etienne c'est que l'ouverture mais chez
part on est à 1 % de chance avant la
partie est peut-être là on est à 5 6%
clairement clairement une grosse
amélioration par rapport au début alors
ça a déjà été joué à cette position avec
l'ouverture et peut-être vraiment en
faveur de de baky vu la situation
là je fais locative à le prendre mais
messi fait petit rock peut-être qu'il va
leur pouvoir jouer avec kafka d'backs
qui comme dans une est indienne reste
qu'avec quatre maintenant ou plus tard
en préparant mais ça c'est pas du tout
genre de position que tu peux avoir avec
magnus tu dois faire nul et tu vas jouer
un truc où tu te prends des pions dessus
et tu te fais attaquer le roi c'est pas
cool à
c'est pas cool du tout
cavalier t5 on nous proposera frk relief
des champions franck si on prend et
après il va jouer la colonne g etc
alors ça reste compliqué mais
ces annonces étaient bien c'est une
position
comme je le disais avec des équilibres
et donc on va avoir une partie d'échecs
by news va pas pouvoir juste faire nul
et passer au prochain tour en
demi-finales sans faire encore un effort
aujourd'hui surtout que là le mec quand
il ya f4 qui part après ça s'attaque
vraiment vite sur le roi c'est vraiment
pas le genre de position que tu es
content d'avoir après dix coups dans
l'ouverture avec les blancs alors
peut-être
il a l'air un peu
le saumon est un peu inquiet le saumon
il prend un f5 ça c'est le coût qui
paraissait le plus logique et maintenant
bas qui a le choix entre dames point f5
direct ou peut-être cavalli f6 d'abord
parce que le seul moyen de protéger ce
pion c'est plus il ya plus g4 maintenant
ceccarelli h4 envoyé grand roque et ça
on est content avec les noirs une
nouvelle fois je sais pas si c'est bon
pas bon mais le truc c'est que dans ce
genre de situation on est content
quoi qu'il a repris de la dame etienne
sans trop réfléchir à et sur cavaliers
dessin qui va jouer gros rock
donc 1
le président qui rend ce concours de
marche en parallèle aubin là il est gros
favori maintenant pour le concours de
marche puisque il joue à un tour de plus
que maxime qui était le favori avant
avant ça je pense pas qu'il puisse être
détrôné labaki dans le concours de
marche
ce que tu vas faire les départage demain
aurait on sait qu'il peut marché en
rapide baky aussi
donc la scène qu'est ce qui va faire ci
fais pas ça il fait rock mais en fait ça
va pas l'empêcher de se prendre un roc
opposé j'aime bien j'aime bien ce que
fait tiennent vraiment cavaliers g5
alors qu'ils avaient les g5 c'est un
coup qu'on n'avait pas c'est quoi l'idée
l'idée c'est quoi parce qu'en fait ceux
placés en le 4 mai ce que sur cavaliers
f6 c'est bizarre carrier g5 ivey d'un f3
rôle [ __ ] des andes
ouais c'est un coup d'enfoirés sa kg 5
il veut faire un nul en force 1 il a
peur de baky magnus il veut échanger les
dames un niveu dame f3 il veut plus très
fier si on joue fawcett skis la dame f3
c'est la question
ça peut être embêtant ça parce que cette
proposition des changes des dames fait
mal hein et des catins évidemment f5
épreuve 5
et ça ça va être très difficile à gagner
voire impossible et g5 c'est malin
qui des quatre direct tu veux faire rock
maintenant cet effet peut-être il a des
dames à quatre échecs et tous et non ça
c'est pas terrible
dans quatre faces mais damas quatre qui
sont relou
cette dame f3 g6 est ce que ça ça peut
aller
des surprises c'est de reprendre du
pillon et de se créer une structure
peut-être plus intéressante
ça peut être une option
il a fait fouet cette maquis ouais si le
cac valeo 4 cavaliers f6 ça va pas de
problème je pense ces dames f300 coup
c'est quand même pleutre un g6 ça peut
être cool
g6 peut être cool hein
g6 pas être coup là
fait cavalier e 4 ha ok donc ils
échangent pas les dames l'absence va qui
a fait cavaler avis
ok on son cavalier les mieux placés en
eux 4 1 il stabilise la position rock et
du coup ça enlève un peu léger kg 5 g4
avec lecavalier en f3 ont là le truc le
plus fort c'est sûrement rock tour des
huit et peut-être c'est de faire b6 des
5 avec de l'activité mais dans ce genre
de partie et ce qu'on ne peut pas tenter
groc
et on clique quoi
à trois peut-être même temps j'ai enfin
peut-être même g5 direct on clique un
truc c'est qu'au pire il va tu vas te
faire ça qui perd champ
ouais ouais en fait ils empêchent joël
roch ce plan est vraiment force assad
sans lèvent un peu le g5 g4
transfert cahier dé 4,1 ça peut être une
manière de continuer
enfin je vais rejouer avec petit recueil
des quatre paquets et des quatre direct
à damas quatre échecs qui est chiant
mais quand on sait par oc écarts et les
d4 peut-être
patrocle rouge lors des 8
essayer de percer à un moment donné mais
bon des 500 signatures qui ont 30
qui sait
est ce qu'il a comme autre option
rokia paquet presse mais qui est prêt si
vous voulez faire j'ai fait un potage
c'est un peu abusé il ya du f4 mais au
pire tu en prends
ouais non ça tend vers la nul très
clairement mais ya rien à faire en fait
aux échecs avec les gens c'est tellement
dur de pas tendre vers la nulle
était de faire grand requin quand même
tant pis un tel roc et tant pis
ouais peut-être pas manquer tant pis
dans tes jouets le plus tout pour le
tout - dans une position pareille dans
cette situation là je ferai grand roque
c'est sûr
et du coup qui réfèrent grand roque mais
bon après c'est plus facile de le faire
à moindre niveau contre carl scène parce
qu'en fait car c'est ni peu de jouer
tous les meilleurs coups tout le temps
mais j'irai plus pour grand roque pour
déstabiliser le jeu une façon car la
scène il le sait 1
envoyez et puis on n'a rien à perdre en
tirons père
meiway grand que ça ça semble être il se
pose la question là etienne en fait il
doit savoir que petit rock et meilleur
fondamentalement mais il doit se
demander si grand roque c'est pas la
manière de déséquilibrer la position et
peut-être de faire vaciller magnus qui
sait
sauf que magnus va pas accepter la nul à
mcnish là il se jette sur une nulle
ainsi peut la prendre
il se qualifie pour hui l'accepterai pas
ce serait vraiment stupide et christophe
jean christophe contre-visite c'est une
prépa c'est sûr fedoseyev tabata bail
ça va jouer le titre final effet 2 va
tenter de mettre la pression et cas rien
que shankland c'était trop de parties
vraiment intéressante
un du coup ils jouent en mode swing home
of swing avec les blancs et ils jouent
contre la française il ajou la vente
avec des 3 5 qui tombe dans une attaque
est indienne ouais c'est beaucoup plus
facile de jouer le gain avec les blancs
qu'avec les noirs un bien évidemment
c'est pour ça que dans un match en deux
parties perdre avec les blancs à la
première est un handicap
immense
eva qui paraît que petit rock elle a dû
juger grand que c'était trop et trop
mauvais
s'affrontaient plus récentes données
contient un cas sévère alors la demi
finale c'est sûr après la finale 6e
si on connaît déjà tous les qualifiés
aux candidats c'est pas sûr c'est pas
sûr du tout donc la demi-finale sur la
finale bon pas sûr parce que fit pas si
les joueurs font des a qualifié
l'événement n'a plus aucun intérêt en
fait
sportivement je dois dire
camp rock c'était peut-être un peu un
peu too much un petit rock il va essayer
de maintenir une pression plus à long
terme un peu comme il l'a fait contre tu
roules sa petite finale qui sera assure
pour les candidats ça dépend si magnus
est en finale c'est magnifiant final oui
on suivra la petite finale
mais là la finale non alors à elle aura
réellement aucun intérêt sportif servir
à rien quoi réellement très clairement
là ça servira vraiment à rien mais le
match pour la troisième place peut avoir
un intérêt c'est faux car la scène veut
la gagner le mec en face va tout faire
pour l'en empêcher alors c'est vrai car
ça ne voudra la gagner
le mec en face à mon avis il s'en foutra
plus ou moins parce que il aura déjà
rempli l'objectif
il ya plein de gens qui veulent plein de
choses dans la vie mais on les filme pas
et on commande pas leur life non plus
quoi enfin là il se trouve que c'est un
événement qui est qualificatif
qualificatif pourquoi pour les candidats
si les les joueurs qualifiés sont déjà
dévoilé le par nature le tournoi n'a
plus d'intérêt sportif en tout cas
bon j'en pause il commenté baky à la
piscine qui va qui va se faire plaisir
en en allant piquer des têtes mais on ne
le fera pas c'est dans toi silva qui a
chantre l'annuler jouer une position
perdante ça dépend près de 6 la position
perdante donne des chances de gain ou
pas et quand même le titre
ouais mais c'est fin c'est un titre en
cartons carton plat québécois s'est tu
as gagné 1 coualy fire quoi bravo mais à
langres au ballet quoi washington soit
sur le palmarès peut vraiment dire ça
y'a qu'à regarder la finale des de la
compétition il ya deux ans par exemple
es tu sens que les joueurs ils sont
venus se qualifier en fait fins puisque
tu t'en fiches de gagner le truc ou pas
après tu joues pas ce que tu joues mais
l'intérêt de la compétition est déjà
passé tu joues pas ce que tu as envie
d'essayer comme quand un mec est déjà
champion du monde de formule 1 et les
derniers grands prix il essaye de les
gagner c'est sûr parce qu'il a envie de
gagner un grand prix plus etc
mais en soit est déjà champion du monde
de formule 1 un bon bah vous les matchs
du psg quand ils sont déjà gagné la
ligue 1 ils jouent encore leur match
quand même mais ils ont déjà réalisé
leur objectif quoi en terme d'argent
soit pas être pareil waimes à ce niveau
là c'est pas des grosses sommes pour ils
sont plus à 30 à 20,36 l'euro près tu
vois ils sont plus à 20,38 leurs prêts à
se leva là
enfin l'intérêt sportif de la
compétition n'existe plus vraiment quoi
magnus ça j'arrive à en gagner et la
qualifie sert à rien donc l'ue doivent
en vouloir à gagner ou un but parce
qu'il a un ego surdimensionné qui va
gagner le truc mais je leur parle là
c'est comme si une équipe de ligue 1 ça
va pas être un bon exemple mais c'est
comme si nadal il a sûrement jamais
gagné les qualifs de roland garros et
qu'il allait se présenter dans le
tournoi de qualification pour pour le
gagner parce qu'il a il n'a pas le droit
de qualifications de roland garros à son
palmarès même s'il a déjà gagné le
tournoi principal 11 ou 12 fois comme
s'ils allaient jouer ces qualifications
et qui remportait le tournoi
qualificatif pas je l'aï serait
peut-être content mais on soit
c'est déjà qualifiés au tour s'arrête
pas à pas quand intérêts quoi magnus
doit quand même se qualifier de
montmagny s'est déjà qualifiée juge
juste le qualified heures comme ça en
fait se faire plaisir parce que c'est
autorisé alors que ça devrait pas l'être
mais ça allez quoi
enfin c'est une anomalie dans le
règlement ouais enfin c'est pas les
qualifiés sont là tu as les meilleurs
joueurs du monde
alors t'as pas 10 milliards n numéro
trois mondial numéro deux mondial
caruana est mauvais dans ce dans ce
format thapan et pau donc il te manque
pour moi dans ce format là les numéros 2
et 3 mondiaux déjà tu peux pas dire que
tu as tous les meilleurs et tapas
radjabov parce que déjà qualifiés les
autres joueurs qualifiés ont pas joué on
peut pas dire qu'ils aient les meilleurs
joueurs du monde qui participe à la
coupe du monde
d'ailleurs quand tu regarderas le
tableau de de magnus à la fin tu verras
qu'il a il a joué peu de deux tops
mondiaux à par baky mais après comme
josé luis là tout à fait enfin j'aurais
pas trop à comprendre votre votre point
de vue c'est juste que lui s'il a envie
de le faire et de le gagner c'est tant
mieux pour lui mais pour un observateur
pour quelqu'un qui regarde d'un oeil
extérieur en fait il n'y a pas d'enjeu
sportif c'est tout ce que je veux dire
c'est comme hier on a regardé le l'aréna
de fab
on s'est bien amusé et qu'enfin fa va
tenter de se qualifier c'était marrant
ou quoi mais ya pas vraiment d'enjeu
sportif c'est plus comme ça quand un
délire ça reste meilleur tournoi de
l'été je vois pas pourquoi il ne le
jouerai pas c'est son métier devient et
wade cheikh aweys pareils fin
comme je disais ce comme tu vas jouer à
coire intertoto par plaisir site est
autorisé ou 20 et c'est difficile de pas
comprendre que ça casse l'équité
sportive pour les autres
même pas magnus tap le million par an ce
n'est pas le cas de price qui change au
riz thaï gagne plus d'un million par an
magnus
c'est parce que ce sont une question
d'ego mais sa toute fin pourquoi pas moi
ce qui m'embête c'est plus c c++ le
règlement qui casse vraiment l'équité
sportive la par exemple baky qui joue à
karl scène en quart de finale de coupe
du monde pour la qualif clairement c'est
le règlement qui le font il est très
pénalisé labaki par le règlement ce qui
leur est beaucoup plus de chances de
battre on va prendre le de joie deuxième
joueur plus fort allez l'eau dans sa
partie de tableau c'est pas karl scène
se serait vide itou duda il aurait quand
même beaucoup plus de chances baky face
à vie dit houdoud a clairement il se
fait enfler par par le règlement bas qui
après voilà il est salutaire match de
gala il est aussi très heureux de jouer
contre carl scène etc
mais d'un point de vue objectif par
rapport à l'équité sportive clairement
bas qui se fait enfler mais mon cher
quoi les gens pensent d'eux dans le
chatt fin peut-être qu'ils n'ont pas
l'intelligence d'écouté mais une
nouvelle fois j'ai absolument un conte
carlson qui va y participer un ça c'est
pas c'est pas lui le souci ici pas du
tout hein
mais ça rien à voir avec le psg qui joue
la coupe de france fin c'est fonder des
choses là c'est un sport individuel d'un
cycle pour le titre de champion du monde
et il ya peu de place pour se qualifier
en plus y'a que six places
qualificatives pour ce championnat et
c'est très difficile d'y aller donc
intéressez-vous aux échecs réellement et
puis vous comprendrez que que enlever
des places dans des qualifs ailleurs ces
problématiques
bah c'est vraiment chaud de pas
comprendre pas des gens ne comprennent
pas juste des gens qui trollent et qui
n'ont pas le kivu qui réfléchissent pas
quoi surtout qu'en plus tu as un haut du
tableau et en bas du tableau donc
clairement celui qui est dans le bas du
tableau est largement à favoriser du
fait qu'ils aient pas karl scène
donc 1
c'est pas parce qu'on fasse quelque
chose qu'on a forcément raison aussi non
mais là c'est enfin j'en ai même parlé
hier avec maxime dans life tu vois que
tous les gens qui suivent les échecs de
prêts font plus ou moins l'unanimité sur
sur ce point de vue là qu'il ya un
problème dans le règlement après c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça mais au bout
d'un moment c'est la logique en fait
j'essaye de faire le truc le plus
équitable possible
c'est comme ça après voilà qui lui pour
la peine il est plutôt content que je
contre magnus donc on peut pas dire que
ça le pénalise en vrai se réjouir sur le
fil le manque d'équité se réjouir de
voir magnus ici bah oui mais pas de
verser quand même injuste pour les
autres sportifs donc tu peux te réjouir
ben ouais mais bon tu bon magnus qu'il
peut il aurait pu jouer d'autres
tournois privés tu te serais réjouis de
le voir jouer deux tournois privés et il
aurait pas gêner l'équité du du tournoi
ça aurait été très bien puis vont se
réjouir
il n'y a pas non plus des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui regardent donc
bon se réjouir quand même de manière
assez limitée 1
on dirait
messieurs les meilleurs du monde tu dois
être capable de battre les meilleurs
joueurs du monde pour être champion du
monde alors ça c'est vrai comme argument
mais c'est pas le mec qui va se
qualifier pour roland garros
en fait son sujet c'est pas forcément de
battre nadal c'est de rentrer dans le
tableau de roland garros et peut-être un
jour d'aller battre nadal mais si
journal en qualifs quand bien même il le
bat déjà il serait pas forcément
qualifié suivant la pareille en bas qui
s'ils gagnent ils seraient pas qualifiés
et en plus de toutes façons l'autre
rendre quand même dans le tableau final
donc tu lui fait pas perdre son titre au
passage je dois dire que si magnus
pouvait perdre son titre ici je dirais
rien en fait ils prendraient un risque
donc le trois des candidats c'est un
tournant un peu sacré aux échecs ces
questions que ce cycle des candidats
c'est un truc un petit peu sacré parce
que tu as tu as tout un combat pour
réussir à arriver à être qualifié pour
jouer contre le champion du monde c'est
un c'est un parcours du combattant c'est
très difficile voie il ya que deux
places à la coupe du monde elles sont
ici dur à gagner il y aura les grands
prix feed c'est vraiment difficile après
les candidats c'est un point qu'il faut
gagner donc c'est vraiment un parcours
du combattant complexe et de l'autre
côté le champion du monde lui il a le
privilège de ne pas avoir à se fatiguer
du coup c'est un privilège quatre
champions du monde et pourquoi pas que
justement du coup il se fatigue pas à
l'huile attendant son fauteuil
tranquille
il prépare ses tournois il se fait sa
saison il a pas il peut cacher ces
prépas et tout ça donc il a vraiment
déjà un avantage par rapport aux
challengers qui font tout le parcours il
ya ce privilège du champion du monde
pourquoi pas c'est comme ça
historiquement dans les échecs mais un
privilège au champion du monde qui est
moins moins grand aujourd'hui qu'il ne
lui était une époque mais il ya ce
privilège qui est là et là du coup bas
en plus de ça non salon il a le
privilège d'être tranquille et
d'attendre mais il a aussi le privilège
de venir et de te prendre des places
quand tu te qualifies quoi donc au bout
d'un moment ça fait quand même beaucoup
quoi ta le beurre l'argent du beurre
tattoo quoi et comme dit tout peut tous
les autres joueurs refusent normalement
de jouer les qualifs ailleurs après
c'est comme ça
c'est que t'as voilà tu as déjà tous ses
privilèges et tout ça et là tu tues tu
viens encore sur un truc du coût qui
n'est pas fait pour toi quoi donc
il a joué rock il a joué f4 mind is ok
il veut vraiment il veut vraiment
échanger aplanir
donc il a fait 4 on va voir mais du coup
sur les ondes comme ça il doit jouer que
le match championnats du monde une fois
tous les deux ans et sinon glander ah
ben non ils jouent tous les tournois
privés tout au long de l'année y en a
plein il ya eu là les grandes chaînes
tours justement qu'il n'a pas joué
il n'a pas accepté de jouer il va y
avoir la cime que phil top le mois
prochain je sais pas si l'âge où il ya
le nord ouest en septembre il ya
énormément de tournois privés tout au
long de la saison aux échecs il peut
aussi jouer les lits comme par exemple
la bundesliga où il peut affronter de
les meilleurs joueurs du monde donc il
ya beaucoup de compétition qui s'ouvre à
lui enfin là vraiment si vous déjà juste
le circuit des grandes chaînes tour plus
le norwich est il aurait pu aller jouer
un tournoi comme biel ou dortmund tu
peux avoir ça aussi tu as le match de
championnat du monde en novembre tu vas
voir weick en janvier donc à yahoo tout
au long de l'année il ya énormément de
tournois qui comptent pas pour le cycle
du championnat du monde aux échecs
d'ailleurs malheureusement je trouve que
ce serait mieux que les tournois compte
dans le dans le cycle personnellement et
qui a une plus grande place aux lots
cependant
bah justement sa part est d'avoir des
tournois différents
est-ce-qu'il objet de prendre bikey ben
je ne pense pas qu'il soit obligé parce
que si son adversaire prend il pourra
reprendre de la dame
maintenant la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est que donne cette structure de
pions et en gros c'est vrai que petit à
petit ça devient de plus en plus dure à
gagner pour baky parce que la structure
elle et elle est très symétriques 1 vous
le voyez ça c'est la structure si on
regarde que les pions c'est une symétrie
total et les pièces blanches sont
légèrement mieux placer sur l'échiquier
alors c'est pas énorme ce qu'on aurait
la casse des 4 mai en soi
on arrive plus facilement à venir a dit
que sur des quatre que le sort des cinq
mais en contrepartie lui la lfh ou le
bon fou qui joue avec les plombs et nous
on a le mauvais donc en soit la position
doit être plus ou moins égales après le
truc c'est que il ya de moins en moins
de choses sur l'échiquier c'est de plus
en plus difficile d'imaginer la gagner
quoi c'est surtout ça
donc
baky s'il prend c'est ce qui va se
passer alors après ce qui peut ne pas
prendre vous proposez tour à 8 dans le
chat alors possible possible il va
peut-être prendre f6 prendre f6 prendre
aux cinq prendre cinq as well as
peut-être qu'on aurait une position
intéressante parce qu'on a quand même un
gros avantage de développement et qui
peut y avoir un problème
donc en fait ils vont peut-être faire un
truc plus stratégique qui veut peut-être
prendre prendre et faire f 5
essayez de vie c'est sûr qu'à ce blanche
et comme dit tout évidemment c'est un
temps qualificatif par définition il
qualifie directement et indirectement on
qualifie directement pour pour les
candidats mais c'est vrai que j'ai
oublié de préciser qu'il qualifie aussi
pour les grands prix fidh donc donc
c'est vraiment un coualy fire qui donne
au final huit places pour pour pour les
joueurs que ce soit directement aux
candidats ou dans un événement
qualificatif aux candidats
après il pourrait aussi faire de cette
coupe du monde juste un tournoi pour
être une coupe du monde sans place au
candidat du coup est ce qu'il a fait
puis emprunt f4 je vais mettre un
refresh soit il a pris en f4
j'ai avoir fou prend f4 d'alger six
dames b3 peut-être à ça va vraiment être
être compliqué donc là il menace ou
prend des 6 un an j'ai vidé dames 6 tout
à l'heure ouais ça va être complexe à
encore mais une coupe du monde semble
s'en rapide à le vainqueur champion du
monde de rapide ça pourrait être cool
pavlo mais il faudra un tableau avec
double élimination où un truc avec des
poules au début mais franchement une
coupe du monde rapide comme ça avec un
titre de champion du monde rapide ce
serait cool c'est vrai que ce serait
très cool et du coup ça prendrait tout
son sens ce serait une vraie coupe du
monde du coup ça donnera un autre titre
un titre dans une autre cadence c'est
plutôt une bonne idée je trouve donc si
on prend il a joué pions prend du
ku'damm g6
ça va être changée en force et bien peur
il va y avoir du dam des cinq échecs fou
g3 il ya tout qui va disparaître
ça n'existe pas la coupe du monde en
rapide hors dia le championnat du monde
de rapides qui a lieu généralement des
cendres c'est un tournoi très sympa à
suivre
ça joue sur trois jours à vrai dire
faire un championnat du monde de rapides
en mode coupe changer le format et faire
un format un peu comme ça je suis
d'accord ça pourrait être un truc
réellement qu'ils font mais c'est vrai
que ça pourrait être un beau format un
format court en mode coupe comme ça en
mode nomade rapide ça pour être
réellement un très beau tournoi
dans cas
le dessin crois je suis fou g3
et ça va échanger
on pourrait faire du 4 x 25 ans on
parlait tout à l'heure avec fap de faire
des formats sur un jour avec quatre
parties rapides donc ça a duré quatre
heures et après en cas de match nul à
faire un tie break qui dure une heure ou
une heure et demie max on pourrait jouer
jouer tous les jours et enchaîner et
sacré neige surtout à lévis et ouais
j'ai vu tout à l'heure ça devait être
prêt par un but à la vitesse à laquelle
ça joue ok ça doit être une finale
qu'ils ont analysé qui doit être nul en
force
parce que ces trois pions contre le
cavalier en finale ça doit finir par un
nul je prendrai les blancs quand même
parce que tu peux te faire bloquer les
pions et le cavalier en fait il ya un
monde peut-être où il atterrit pour
gagner à six meilleurs merkel sera sur
les spectacles la qualité quelque chose
entre 20 et 25 minutes puisque dix
secondes par coup les joueurs jouent
déjà super bien vous avez vu la partie
de maxime contre car yakine le match ça
va envoyer du très lourd en défense en
attaque ils ont été assez impressionnant
les deux donc ça se fait dossier
tabatabaei on n'a pas le bon iranien
intéressant nous on sera pour tabatabai
avec fable si un départage de bain très
très clairement sera notre note petit
joueur à moins qu'ils aient shankland
méchante landes va se qualifier les amis
la chambre l'a en fait nous on espère
avec femme à avoir une qualification de
visites contre duda et d'avoir tabataba
et et chant claude histoire d'être bien
sûr d'avoir les joueurs les plus faibles
possibles aux candidats pourquoi parce
que ça nous fait marrer
donc on est on est pour les joueurs les
plus faibles et des arts en plus si
maxime se qualifie après aux candidats
au moins il y aura des plots dans le
tournoi c'est vrai que pas donner de
place aux candidats au vélo c'était un
petit peu surprenant après je peux
comprendre qu'ils aient fait ça parce
qu'il ya la crise qu vide qui a duré
longtemps il est peu de tournois qu'ils
ont pu vouloir éviter ce vélo qui est
tronqué après il faudrait un jour
finalement arriver à un système
j'ai envie de dire
deux points à l'année via les tournois
et c'est d'avoir un vrai lieu entre les
tournois mais ça on n'y arrivera pas
avant une bonne quinzaine d'années
ça marche quand les placerait lyon n'a
pas cette année mais allez les années
précédentes il y avait une moyenne lots
sur l'année et c'était cette moyenne
l'acquis qui comptait pour le meilleur
classement sur l'année important dehors
des pnj au candidat ben oui ça va être
un peu marrant c'est un tabac tabac et
aux candidats voiture et le galilée
26-30 coiffe un fouillis la goyave 2613
naturel c'est quand même mon candidat
c'est ouf je sais pas ce sera
intéressant ça met du piment sita
tabataba et et
et shankland tu es quand même très bien
passé beaucoup à jean claude hill à
calage maintenant ça me chante landes
nature elle s'est complètement
improbable il a quel âge chaque land je
vais regarder j'ai jeté un oeil
gênant 91 voix il a déjà 30 ans il a une
petite phase descendante tu vois tu
t'attends pas à voir champlan nos
candidats ce serait beau quoi on va être
pour les petits poucet quoi les gars à
qui tu aurais donné 1 % de chance après
vie dit ça m'étonne déjà - mais bon
tabataba essai c'est juste impossible
tabatabai je sais même pas si les top
100 mondial serait extraordinaire après
il n'y est pas encore après il n'y est
pas encore mois après il c'est un jeune
joueur il a 20 ans
207e mondial s'étonnant 207e mondial ce
serait une énorme perte ça me fait un
peut pas penser à la perte de khar a de
cfa à l'australian si on parle un peu
tennis étonnant de voir ce quart à 2,5
l'arrivée arriver aussi loin
un futur grand joueur tout à fait
possible on ne sait pas un en tout cas
en tout cas c'est une perte serait une
performance majuscule filiale mais bon
il faut encore gagner deux matches ça va
être difficile mais un jeu ça me ferait
plaisir vu les joueurs qui à devoir y
arriver
104e mondiale plus tard hathaway dans
les jours actif dans les joueurs actifs
c'est exact mais bon va être de mauvaise
foi on va pas prendre que les joueurs
actifs on va prendre tous les joueurs
classés méchant cloud ce serait beau
parce que c'est vraiment un mec c'est
que au boulot hein
c'est un énorme bosseur shankland
peyrens pire on va le mec il est auteur
de livres il est prof il joue à côté
machin enfin il donne tout champ clos
jean-claude souvient on le sait par
l'étape us j'ai impression c'est vrai et
là ce sera marrant parce que je lis a de
grandes chances qu'il soit le seul
joueur américain est allé
c'est quoi le concept champions qui
n'auraient pas de talent c'est lui-même
qui le dit faut suivre son twitter je
suis le sweet as de la chance tu l'as
dit que quand t'as pas talents comme les
mises à part réussir entre que t'as pas
le choix que de réussir en travaillant
ces chants cloud qu'il le dit et il peut
prouver à tous les gens qui sont qui
sont le chat qu'on peut on peut y
arriver juste juste en travaillant
énormément et ça c'est quand même un
beau message envoyé un d'avoir un joueur
comme ça qui a acquis qui est juste un
monstre de travail et qui envoie
j'ai carte blanche quel système on
ferait pour faire les candidats mais en
fait j'avais carte blanche sur un
système où tous les grands tournois
privés en fait donnerait des points sur
un système de points qui réunira tous
les gros tournois dans l'année donc j'ai
pas il y aurait peut-être vingtaine de
tournois ou 25 tournois qui seraient
pris et à et tous ces tournois donnerait
des points en fête et à la fin ce les 7
les sept ou huit plus fort sur combien
de voir nos candidats héros candidats et
après pour moi je mettrais un format
matx en fait aux candidats les matches
en quatre parties parce que le match
championnat du monde après c'est c'est
aussi en match c'est pas un tournoi pour
voir de ces joueurs là lequel est le
meilleur
et après on ferait le match championnats
du monde comme ça tout létourneau tout
au long de l'année aurait un enjeu en
fait ce serait toujours l'enjeu serait
de se qualifier aux candidats et une
fois qu'on a gagné mais une fois qu'on
est et qu'on s'est qualifié on va aux
candidats et peut-être que moi je
mettrais cette place et jean laisserai
une au vainqueur 2-2 au champion du
monde et du coup il se retrouvera huit
pour aller jouer le titre ou quelque
chose comme ça donc ce serait comme ça
mais c'est ouf quand même on est sûr et
certain qu'au moins shankland ou
tabatabai son candidat a maintenant ils
peuvent tous les deux perdent
aujourd'hui le marocain aucune place à
l'ailé maintenant puisque dans fait
hurler tour un privé que tu dois jouer
et tu marques des points suivants tes
résultats
le fan des systèmes sans vérification
situés sur des joueurs qui n'en
bénéficient pas ah oui mais il y aurait
un cahier des charges pour les tournois
qualificatifs tard zelda sayre que tous
les tournois de l'année
il devrait y avoir un turnover enfin il
se passerait quelque chose quoi des
qualifs ailleurs des machins enfin il
faudrait refaire le système de a à z
mais j'essaierai de faire quelque chose
dans cet esprit là
bah ouais pourrait faire un genre de
grands circuits sur l'année avec 30 40
joueurs dedans et voilà quoi et tous les
ans rebelote mais
ça permettrait surtout de oued de
redonner un coup de fouet aux échecs
parce que du coup des tournants
importants en réalité là cette année y
en a quelques-uns pascal co vide mais
l'année prochaine
bon il va encore y avoir les candidats
mais dans deux ans en fait on va être
sur une année on va avoir la coupe du
monde
les grands prix fidh en fait il va y
avoir 4 tournant intéressant dans
l'année simplement dans deux ans
atp protégé par un peu trop parlé plus
tôt par m ce peut-être trop pyramidale
balla le système messieurs échec est
beaucoup plus pyramidale encore un
il faudra y réfléchir mais quelque chose
dans cet esprit là en tout cas serait
pas trop tu en as pour les joueurs à
voir les joueurs et je vous déjà
beaucoup hein c'est leur métier après
trottoirs pour les joueurs c'est leur
métier
s'il doit jouer sept huit tournois par
an ça fait quoi sept tournois par an
fois on va dire 10 rondes en moyenne ça
fait 70 parties par en plus pour ceux
qui se qualifient
du coup du coup les candidats encore
encore 12 ça fait 82 parties sur une
année cc beaucoup hein
si tu joues tous les tournants après tu
peux refuser tu peux te reposer et
refuser mais finalement il joue déjà au
temps avec les gaules et les grandes
chaînes tour les coupes du monde les et
tous les tons a privé qui a dans l'année
les bundesliga les machins l'ailé top 12
il les joue déjà en fait les parties
celui qui va se taper les grands prix
fidh tous les khalifes ailleurs la coupe
du monde
un grand prix fields il va y en avoir
deux ou trois je sais plus on va dire
d'eux mais je crois que ces trois line
of men certes on assure sur 13 rhône on
va dire 4 parce qu'entre les grands prix
les machins à dire ça fait déjà quatre
la coupe du monde c'est un tournoi mes
galons ça fait 5
ils ont déjà cinq tournois pour celui
qui se qualifie aux candidats ça va en
faire six est plus sous les troncs a
privé qui joue la sinne que phil cup
norwich s il y avait le lus grande
gestion du carré suggest euros zagreb le
grand test pour paris
en réalité ils les ont déjà allés les 70
jours de compétitions par an quoi qu'il
en soit le top-12 la coupe du monde le
machin le la bundesliga d' certains qui
jouent d'autres ligues enfin le
championnat d'europe par équipe les
olympiades enfin au bout d'un moment tu
vas tu vas tu as les avoir les joueurs
de tournois jouent ils jouent beaucoup
il joue beaucoup mais c'est comme ça
c'est leur métier quoi comme des cinq
signes de caïds et 5 ça allait aussi un
la magnus il veut il en gestion il veut
échanger
pourquoi il se lève et y marcher les
seuils pas de quelques les coûts de carl
sense qui se détend tu peux pas être en
et forme constant dans une partie
d'échecs c'est long et a besoin d'aller
marcher dalle et aérer l'esprit
cependant il réfléchit quand même à la
position il n'a pas besoin de l'avoir
pour pour y penser
la menace ça doit être qu'il prend 1,7
et dame prend des six a battu comme baky
away ya un piège sur dame prend 1,4
alors ça a l'air terribles à tour eu un
sûrement on peut pas prendre un f4 on va
se faire prendre cet or est ce que on
peut réussir à se venger
surtout province et oui mais il faut
prendre si c'est ça l'idée donc qui sait
ça enfin deux variantes qui change tout
pour 1 dames c4 ça semble marcher
puisque on tape sur le fou est en fait
il peut prendre les prendre à noter
qu'il ya peut-être des trois ou six ans
donc sur cavani desing comment il va
jouer
faire trois des huit épreuves cette qui
apprend le 7 et essayer de jouer ça et
pourra faire après peut-être dame me
cissé ramener le carré en d4
tu pourras aussi organiser des tournois
privés en forme de mini circuit
d'ailleurs pour les candidats avec des
petites places par deux trois circuits
enfin des solutions au ski et le fou il
ya des huîtres m&i par où le fou en fait
il faudrait qu'il arrive en d4 ici
serait bien cette fois f6 sur fou prend
des six coups des quatre échecs dames
prend des six sur quels points f6
tourcoing f6 d'amd 5,3 à suite au
dernier carré des quatre peut-être
tenter un truc comme ça
peut-être tentés info f6 sa force un peu
la main et ça permet de reprendre du
kava les deux de la tour quand le car
elle y prend
ça peut être une option
on n'a pas peur de cavaliers c'est cette
offre f6 ki67 ont passé impressionne pas
trop en fait peut-être commencer par
food et 4 pour contre la case aussi se
faire tour c'est 8
je tenterai bien fois f6 personnes
pressées pas forcément le coup de
l'année mais pourquoi pas
ça peut être ça peut être une option
pas du tout même après pas forcé pas
jamais dit que c'était le meilleur coût
1 mais ça une tête d'un coût auquel tu
pense en tout cas très clairement
une dépression immortal vu les longues
mais un format coupe du monde ce serait
pareil on peut virer de jeu ah non pas
du tout ah non non moi c'est absolument
impossible for mac ou du monde tu me
ferait pas jouer
impossible j'ai assez fait
enfin coupe du monde anglais abbaoui a
même en rapide à format coupe du monde
en rapide je serais très heureux de
tenter un jamais su ressortir sortir un
beau joueur possible
5 + 3 en 3 + 2 le blitz et soit 3 + 0
pour les vrais 3 mois à 3 + 2 pour les
pleutres 5 + 3 j'appelle pas ça du blitz
c'est une cadence trop pleutres
après ma meilleure cadence camp quand
j'étais jeune ce tte 15 + 10 c'est la
cadence où je jouais le mieux ce que
j'ai hésité pas à mettre un peu mal au
temps et j'avais une bonne accélération
après trois cd longue un aimant la croix
lensois gt gt pas le but c'était pas ma
meilleure cadence même si vous pouvez le
penser aujourd'hui ma mère cadence était
rapide parce que j'avais j'étais assez
complet pour jeu dur rapide
j'étais bien à la fin pour finir vite et
je voyais bien les tactiques et je
réussissais à utiliser le temps imparti
de manière constructive
donc c'était pas mal j'étais souvent mal
autant donc un squeeze je me mettais
souvent moins bien autant que mes
adversaires mais à mais j'avais le temps
de bien réfléchir et de me mettre dans
des positions agréable et donc ça me
réussissait plutôt bien géré et elle est
partie quand il fait chaud et que tu
t'es mis au bliss va je me suis arrêté
well et partir je souhaite m'en arrêter
quand j'ai commencé de travailler en
fait j'ai commencé déjà j'aimais pas
trop de base mais après j'ai commencé à
penser que c'était trop de temps à
passer pour une partie d'un jeu ça me
paraît fou en fait aujourd'hui
pas pour les joueurs pros s'ils ont
envie ou pas les gens qui aiment et qui
sont pros ou ceux qui ont envie de le
faire ça ça va mais moi les dépenses et
sept ou huit jours de vacances pour
aller jouer un tournoi ça me paraît fou
de passer autant de temps pour jouer aux
échecs
une partie je veux dire
jojo les conjuguer il ya dix ans
donnerait quoi bon faudrait plutôt dire
quinze 15 ans il ya 15 ans je vais être
quand même meilleur qu'aujourd'hui en
rapide parce que je perds fait souvent à
entre prénom en buts je serai plus fort
aujourd'hui en rapide plus fort avant
ouais puisqu'en rapide je perds fait à
2005 je pense en général je joue à 2005
en rapide ouais je vais jouer 25 25
clairement même j'étais bien au rapide
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai
pas de répertoire à l'époque j'en avais
un aujourd'hui avec un répertoire je
serai plus fort qu'en rapide à l'époque
à l'époque où elle jouait bien 24 50 25
très clairement
vous pouvez faire des beaux des beaux
résultats
vous pouvez faire des beaux résultats
j'ai perdu mon cahier rsa maman avait
pas quoi j'étais bien préparé j'avais
des bonnes idées
c'est facile préparer le cahier non à la
fin je le prépare est tout seul en fait
oui comment la fédé n'ont jamais été un
grand espoir c'est moi comme j'ai
souvent dit hein tu prends ma cage
aurait pu faire au maximum 2006 fit tu
vois farce et rien pas sa ceinture sert
à rien en vrai et ça c'était grand
maximum c'était genre un rêve sûrement
j'aurais fait 25 25 50
donc non tu sers à rien en gros enfin
c'est pour pour du sport de haut niveau
c'est médiocre faut enfin non mais faut
dire les choses comme elles sont enfin
c'est un de s'inventer des life
j'aurais pu obtenir un niveau médiocre
pour du pro am et même la regarde la
coupe du monde fera ensuite si on suit
pas qui a été top 10 mondial ont su mvl
ont suffi route chat un chat le niveau
que j'aurais pu atteindre en max ses
niveaux de maury dhabi adi qui s'est
fait écraser par maxime frature bout
d'un moment faut être réaliste devant
gay courra rigueur calcul il manquait
calcul et d'aimer ça aussi non pour du
pro en dessous de 2700 c'est enfin
autant tf1 n'en existe pas quoi non mais
c'est clair n'existe pas
c'est l'enfer lambda est médiocre pour
un pro ben oui c'est ça c'est ça hugo et
non faut juste en être conscient en fait
c'est juste que tu vois la tute un
joueur récréatif quoi en vrai enfin
mathieu existe papin pas au top niveau
on enfin tu vas jamais les suivre en
demi finales des coupes du monde
probablement enfin - sur un exploit mais
tu menacera jamais de faire quoi que ce
soit en fait au moins 2700 pour menacer
non c'est comme ça
c'est juste avec ce it out jacques dans
le dans le chat la chance que j'ai eue
c'est que j'ai compris rapidement et
j'espère que les les jeunes le
comprendre aussi vite que moi s'ils
peuvent pas faire carrière dans leur
sport que bassa servent à rien en fait
c'est le mieux le comprendre à 17-18 ans
qu'à 23 24 c'est quoi la différence
entre 2500 et 2700 souvent ce qui fait
le plus de différence c'est la vitesse
de calcul
après il ya le travail aussi la
connaissance des ouvertures de la
stratégie etc mais mais généralement le
truc inné qui fait vraiment la
différence c'est la vitesse de calcul
nantes est un élève qui est sortie en
championne du monde tu regardais souton
coutu conseillerais d'aller voir mieux
un mec mieux classés alors en fait quand
tu donne des cours à quelqu'un c'est
plus le cas je le fais plus mais faut
voir si tu peux lui apporter quelque
chose
en fait tant que tu lui apporte quelque
chose et que tu penses que c'est bien
mais il faut garder ton élèves et le
jour où tu penses qu'il ya quelqu'un
d'autre qui peut lui apporter plus bas
il faut changer d'élèves en fait il faut
changer de profs je dirai tout a changé
d'élèves
donc après à tout niveau tu vois c'est
un joueur qui peut devenir champion du
monde mais qui à sept ans et demi et qui
est pour le moment en 1900 2000
peut-être tu peux lui apporter plein de
choses et après et après un peu plus
tard il devient plus fort est bien plus
fort que toi ou où l'écart de niveau est
plus suffisant il ya des choses que tu
ne voudrais pouvoir lui apprendre et que
tu peux pas lui apprendre et ben tu une
passe à quelqu'un de plus fort n'a
presque pas toujours pas forcément ce
qu'un mec est bien classé et qu'il est
très fort qui va pouvoir bien enseigner
non plus disons qu'il faut un niveau
minimum
évidemment tu as cité 1900 2000 c'est
difficile de vraiment entraîné donner
des bons conseils faut déjà avoir un
niveau un peu supérieur choix que pour
être entraîneur d'après la ffe je crois
que c'est 2002 la limite pourquoi pas tu
vois ça me paraît être un hello correct
tu vois mais après c'est au cas par cas
suivants les joueurs enfin il ya
beaucoup de cas après il faut être
pédagogue aussi kate winslet mais il
faut un set pour pouvoir être pédagogue
il faut un certain niveau
parce que sinon tu fais des belles
phrases mais ça sert pas à grand chose
c'est il ya ça aussi
roy mathieu et sa femme vont pas tenter
leur chance comme étienne by tiennent
ils étaient file était le plus jeune
grand maître du monde il a un talent
incroyable etienne je pense que etienne
à 18 ans il devait déjà être quasiment
être top 50 mondial l'ont déjà je vous
lui demanderez je vais par la biographie
détiennent en tête à 18 19 ans il devait
déjà être dans le top mondial en fait il
est incroyable etienne les fenêtres 2005
pour être finalement entraîneur ouais tu
vois moi j'aurais dit 2002 et 2100 ça me
paraît aussi être être quelque chose
en fait c'était moins fort tu peux pas
vraiment faim tu peux être pédagogue
pour les gens qui débutent vraiment tu
peux être initiateur ou quoi mais mais
il faut quand même une certaine vision
du jeu pour pouvoir avoir une certaine
pédagogie aussi quoi
j'ai fait un voyage avec dorfman qui a
entraîné etienne et caspar a filmé
indique etienne était clairement plus
doué que gary ça c'est une balle un faux
et robin mais tiennent c'est un talent
incroyable très clairement après les
entraînements les entraîneurs des fois
ils disent ça mais il voit pas le cas
ils ont un genre de biais cognitif
il oublie certains points forts qu'ont
certains joueurs dire par là que des
fois tu as des gens je parle pas du tout
je fais veulent tous se sont entendus
par rapport à etienne et et gary parce
que j'ai payé aucune opinion là dessus
mais eux je leur parle avec des fois des
joueurs qui sont un peu moins de doué
mais c'est plus débat tant ils sont
forts dans les moments difficiles genre
par exemple car iaquinta peut être un
bon exemple tu vois tout au long de
l'année
tu te dis que bon il est fort mais il
est jamais top 5 mondial et tout d'un
coup tu le vois dans des matches au
couteau comme son match contre carl
scène et le mec va développer un jeu
incroyable je repars avec des fois tu as
des tatas des personnes qui ont un
certain niveau à l'entraînement avec
compétition mais qui sont capables de se
sublimer
justement quand l'enjeu devient devient
important et parfois al'inverse les
joueurs qui sont très forts à
l'entraînement mais qui face à une haute
dose de pression comment ça a moins bien
joué même parfois il ya aussi ce truc là
qui rentre en compte et je crois
kasparov
c'était vraiment une bête de compétition
quoi sert que plus tu mettais d'enjeux
mieux y jouer et j'ai pas d'avis sur
etienne par rapport à ça mais c'est plus
sûr kasparov qui me paraît être un
compétiteur de folie quoi
à la réalité du ray n'est pas toujours
celle de l'entraînement way
bam détroit jouer mon etienne le truc
qui écoute qui affirme être le caméléon
des 4/10 pas bien quoi enfin il réussit
à avoir une position c'est bien ce qui
fait
et puis bon kasparov il a aussi eu la
chance entre guillemets de jouer ce
match à rallonge contre karpov son
premier match pour le titre de champion
du monde à moscou
parce que ça lui a permis je sais plus
quand ils ont volé deux parties une
quarantaine dont une cinquantaine c'est
un truc de ouf
il ya quelqu'un dans le chat qui va
savoir mais à ça lui a permis d
énormément joué contre karpov et ça l'à
beaucoup fait progresser
parti avec 48 parties le premier match
mc c'est fou comment ça fait progresser
tous et 48 parties contre le meilleur
joueur du monde
karpov car pas faux si c'est un joueur
énorme enfin
comme des robes inside dans le chatt ya
aussi des choix de vie après affaires
faut être prêt à sacrifier tout le reste
pour arriver tout en haut pas forcément
ce qui te rend le plus heureux ya aussi
un ce que tu as vraiment envie de faire
tous ses efforts pour pour ça sacrifier
un peu tout toute la vie tous les à
côtés pour pour être le meilleur
pousseurs de bois du monde a précédé
caractère ces évocations toujours à ce
sujet complexe ça
et c'est vraiment plus qu'à l'époque
comme les parties n'étaient pas
accessibles toutes les parties n'étaient
pas accessibles y avait pas les
ordinateurs pour s'entraîner et c'est
aujourd'hui tu peux t'entraîner est
quasiment en jouant à haut niveau avec
l'ordinateur en analysant etc
à cette époque-là pouvoir jouer des
matchs de quarante parties contre karpov
ça ça te faisait progresser d'une façon
à juste exponentielle quoi
dans mon cas
ba qui est ce qui va tenter le quai des
cats pas encore une position on
s'enflamme pour le moment ça reste assez
assez plat mais qui sait on attend on
attend de vibrer une erreur peut-être de
magnus bas qui en tout cas il tente où
il fait sa partie
attention à cavaillon cet art qui a eu 7
c'est un coup qu'on espère en fait faut
prendre cette ça ferait plaisir
en d4 pas mal aux sirènes des cats est
pas mal aussi sondé joli coup ça je vois
bien faire cailler des quatre moi perso
mais bon
il ya des quatre ou trois têtes on prend
à ce moment là sur et chaque ya pas
attendre cavaliers ou cette dame prend
et héros à schwyz
essayez de taper sur quatre
j'ai tu n'y crois pas mais c'est
difficile d'y croire pour le moment on
joue sur une faute un magnus il serre la
vis
je vous dis à 5 % de chances de gagner
donc c'est difficile pour le monde
s'enflamme et on attend une erreur on
attend une étincelle sun ska et des
parties longues l'étincelle mais des
heures arrivée
on va voir on attend pour le moment mais
c'est difficile de s'enflammer sur une
position comme ça hein
vraiment faut vraiment attendre qu'on
espère une erreur de magnus pour le
moment la position offre malheureusement
pas énormément de jeu mais qui sait
donc 1
ace combat qui va réussir à trouver
quelque chose
et b4 non c'est pas compliqué juste
faire quel point b 4 et casser la
structure
qui réfléchit doigts et doit essayer des
failles doit espérer trouver un coût qui
gêne
terrible terrible terrible pour notre
baky magnus a vraiment très bien serrer
la vis
donc il ordonne 00 non mais là ça se
voit enfin legalis et honnêtement il n'y
a pas besoin de turbines y siens pour
voir que ben la position elle est dur à
percer les noirs sont pas moins bien
mais c'est difficile de jouer le lien
ici quand bien même tu gagnes +14 ce
sera encore difficile de gagner
il a joué car ils étaient quatre
stresse un peu pour bâti voit pas trop
d'options ici
complexe
avec minutie stress et qu'il fasse une
faute ça me paraît pas être le genre de
positions dans lequel ça peut arriver le
seul truc qui peut arriver c'est qu'ils
veuillent trop faire nul mais il a
tellement d'expérience magnus
c'est le seul chose seul point positif
c'est qu'il a réussi à casser la
symétrie
un truc qui peut mettre le four en g3
les conserver les faux ce qu'il peut
échanger
est ce qu'un peu mieux pour les noirs
peut-être un peu plus agréable mais je
vois pas du tout comment progresse à
partir de là aura tenté 1 h 4 hh 5h 4h 3
et rfo à tenter quelque chose
le truc c'est qu'on peut un peu là je
vous laisserai contre pioro nous quoi je
suis très confiant un lacet jusque
contre magnus ça me paraît pas assez
pour le faire vaciller
ça paraît un peu léger quoi
ça me paraît
un peu léger en terme de pression
j'avais quelque chose qui fasse plus
plus peur mais f après que magnus glisse
peut-être petit à petit
et après ce cas il a choqué des cas je
croyais un petit bug on va espérer un
dame c'est 3-1 et kiko hasard un petit
dame g3 thiam g3 ça a l'air d'être un
joli couvre y avait lieu de ça ferait
plaisir surtout vu la performance de
magnus hier il a été on analyser la
partie avec fabre ce matin on vous
impose ses stars sur les coups de 10h30
mais il a vraiment été très très
impressionnant et magnus hier
un joli coup allez magnus un petit dame
g3 ferait plaisir
reste qu'il peut sauver en tout cas ce
qui est ce qui fait plaisir quand même
c'est que magnus et respecte le
président il n'a pas joué le gain depuis
le début de la partie
il respecte le président il en a peur
magnus et ça c'est quand même une une
bonne chose il a fait le fou g31 je
crois
c'est par la bonne pièce sur g3 magnus
il n'a pas mis la bonne pièce sur g3
terrible
c'est terrible
tiens on y va continuer comment est ce
qu'il va faire tour à huit mois je
voyais bien fait retour à huit personnes
complexe
un petit fou à 6,2 balibar fois cavalier
7 serait dommage pour etienne de filer à
dame en un
100% nul je sais pas mais mais on est
sur du 99 % 1
c'est dur c'est toujours dur c'est ma
swing avec les noirs
bon il va faire quoi toi mais tour à 8
soit 3,8 pas les tours à huit peut-être
image un retournement de situation et on
ya cru mais hier il a bien joué en vain
à qui il a fait sa partie il n'était pas
loin un couperet ah c'est sûr qu'on
aurait plus vivre et si bas qu'ils
avaient fait nul hier la défaite a fait
mal mais bon on se garde encore le droit
d'espérer l'espère adha
on trouvait le lien avec les non il n'y
a pas de gain va les amis 1 comme je le
disais la faut juste jouer des coups
essayer de maintenir matière la pression
maintenir une position la plus complexe
possible même si c'est dur et espérer
que ça nul ici à un moment donné c'est
tout ce qu'on peut faire
absolument rien d'autre n'est possible
so lu ment rien d'autre n'est possible
au hasard ouais je pense qu'arsène paca
soit c'est tout les dormeurs niveau à le
dernier champion du monde est quasiment
toujours plus fort que le précédent donc
oui tout là qu'il ya un gros écart en
termes d'années
on va regarder 1h47 a fait un match nul
plus
déjà une heure quarante on aurait tapé à
95% de chances que ça dure deux heures
de plus pour qu'il se passerait remet
après
après voilà on vit sur l'espoir un
espoir qui se passe quelque chose
il se passait des choses se passaient
moins 200 personnes bah oui mais bon il
faut dire la vérité quoi je pense que
qui a échangé il va faire tout rue89
pense que c'est important quand on casse
que caste des événements qu'on cache pas
la nature de de ce qu'on regarde au
public 1 c'est comme ne pas faire croire
que cette coupe du monde donne un titre
de champion du monde au genre de choses
je pense c'est important d'avoir un une
transparence 1
je pense qu'il va hausser l'âge et les
shows à la fin à partir il va rester
assez prudent il va faire ce qu'il peut
faire
il ne peut pas faire plus pour le moment
donc la position dont on a parlé nous il
ya une demi-heure après tour et je vous
disais il ya peut-être un peu plus
agréable à jouer pour les noirs mais il
n'y a rien il n'y a pas moyen de
rajouter de la pression qui va devoir
tenter quelque chose peut-être à base h
5 h 4 comme je vous le disais là on
espère une faute et l'erreur elle peut
arriver si magnus 6e mais à trop vouloir
contrôler à à se retrouver dans un genre
de entre deux où il sait plus s'il doit
jouer pour gagner pour faire nul et à ce
moment là on pourrait avoir un
un retournement de situation
c'est vraiment la seule à la seule
solution
question ce qu'a fait bien sur un plan à
long terme plutôt sur une tactique et le
calcul mais plutôt sur une attitude à
moi est sûre sur une attitude de plan à
moyen terme est pour moi c'est là dessus
que peut venir l'erreur
puis avoir un craquage un craquage parce
que parce qu'on veut trop on veut trop
contrôler un bac à thumeries quatre
matches est qualifiée pour les grands
prix vite ce qui est super ah oui oui le
résultat de ba qui sera de toute façon
positif à la suite de ce tournant là
après c'est sûr que avec avec trois
français en piste on espérait forcément
avoir un joueur qui menace une
qualification candidats ciba qui perd là
ce sera pas le cas cette fois ci et on
espérera que ce sera le cas au tour
prochain quoi aof au tournoi prochain
on peut faire un petit tour sur les
autres échiquiers doux d'avis dit ça
quand je dis moi je jouerai plus tôt
avec les blancs ça l'a quand même même
si elle doit être nul feda stava tabac
et où la savate sûrs vaudroz ça ira en
départage on suivra ça demain alléchant
cloud car yakine ça va être bouillant
c'est quand le prochain dans le khalife
sera le grand suisse alors j'avais les
dates je vais les reprendre pour pas
dire de bêtises
du 27 octobre au 7 novembre
tous les trois ou cinq jours et nous
fait avec les départage sinon c'est la
sieste harbaoui il faut bien
khattak peur de rien bah il a raison 1
enfin avoir un mental de fou pour la
jouer taper 4 heures de gamme que tu
sais que tu as un pour cent de chances
de la wii ne m'aime pas après tu penses
pas tu kiffes le moment façon tu es
obligé de jouer tu es loin de chez toi
tu y vas tu joues un
tu vas tu joues point bas rhin
as tu fous tu te fais plaisir et puis ça
passe ça passe 1 et si ça passe pas ça
passe pas envie de dire
j'aurai la moitié des grands prix s'ils
n'étaient pas qualifiées par et grâce à
la coupe du monde ils n'auraient pas pu
les jouets à bailleau donc
automatiquement non
il a joué tour à écouter c'est
exactement la position qu'on a vu
maintenant il ya presque une heure je
voyais pas de plan de gains ici
je pense qu'il va tenter h 5 h 4 baki
qu'ils envoient h5 ouais c'est
exactement ce qu'ont ce qu'on pensait on
va voir comment comment ça évolue il
tente tout bas qu'il envoie tout je dois
être quand même content la position
qu'il a eue par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé dans l'ouverture
ils menacent h4 maintenant espère
peut-être réussi à renvoyer le pion h36
piaillements h3 et qui forçait g3 ça ce
serait cool parce que ça donnerait des
cases blanches autour du roi et ça
pourrait poser problème
magnus qui a pas l'air aussi à l'aise
que ça la position semble encore bien
trop facile mais quand mamie monde des
petits signes inquiétants allez il peut
il peut y avoir un petit une petite
vibration les petites vibrations
il sut
le 5-1 coup alors pure et simple ce
serait vraiment l'embellie 1 pour baky
ça permettrait dame prend dame
ce serait une belle une belle chose en
tout cas sur ces deux partis bas qui
n'aura pas à rougir 1 hier il a quand
même sorti sa game et aujourd'hui il
continue à faire à faire le taf
je crois qu'il ya eu h 4 de la part de
minus
serre la vis de partout le mind russe
5 h 4
il a fait h3 je pense à me paraît très
inférieurs comme beaucoup mais bon c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas grand chose est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas une mare à loutre ici
la phase 3 est ce qu'on appelle un fou
des deux ambulant à l'idée sur d'un
brandy on adam pranger trois tours ici
on n'a pas un tour prend un carton
ambulant
un problème ce qui a créé dieu cet échec
et il joue sur le clouage de la tour
pour gagner la dame
donc il a fallu trois ans d'après vous
le coup qui n'arrive pas
ça valait le coup est arrivé est ce
qu'on peut
est ce qu'on peut avoir une magouille
est un truc y avait pour moi non plus
petit que pour vous donc c'est difficile
à voir
comment s'organiser
- est-ce qu'on peut faire
encore un petit quelque chose j'ai avalé
en d4 il est fort
j 3 h 7 meilleurs pour ça que j'aime
bien et en même temps je suis pas sûr
est-ce que touré fuite ça peut être une
idée essayer de faire car élèves trois
pions transfo h4
faire tour f1 en fait juste rieter
arrêts
durand
bon d'accord moi je sais je suis pas
contre ça protège la dame il peut y
avoir des petits trucs quoi
vous assistent b 5 mois sur un 6/6 peut
toujours faire un 4 en vrai huit fois
c'est un kaoua ne peut passer par fou
des deux en fait on aurait fait un x 5
mais ils font à 5 à vrai dire il sert
pas à grand chose
donc
à voir comment ils continuent à pas il
n'y a pas vraiment de recette miracle et
shankland un échange entre ses hyper
chaud c'est complètement guéant pour
jean-claude vous êtes complètement fou
terrible c'est bouillant ça en fait
c'est hyper complexe comme position
il a fait rage sept
enfin quand c'est pas sûr qu'il la gagne
mais alors du tout du tout
jamie le rail en f4 j'ai eu l'impression
que c'était faux f2 le coup mais il a
mis le carélien f400 qu'il a fait car et
des f4 et kafka ne peut pas échanger
essayer de jouer le elle a fait preuve
de pour moi faisait était le coup mais
je sais pas j'ai l'impression que
c'était un coup vers l'arrière j'ai pas
vu en direct
vous imaginez peut-être fou d2f ou des
deux j'aime bien l'idée sur dame prend
les deux cavaliers f3 un petit pied jose
salaris que ça marche mais alors au fc
être fou des deux tours f1 reprend 1,4
ça ça passe du coup il veut fou des deux
tours d un
et donc je vous prends
en d2 foot au point 4 et si je fais fou
à 5
il va vouloir b 4 des 8 et tours
ok bakic à jouer qui avait laissé 6
okc lycées 6 il veut quoi il veut
cavalier e 5 il a joué à troyes magnus
j'ai l'impression ou p3 pour consolider
à ses 4 c'était plutôt b3 d'ailleurs
parce que sur a3 je pense qu'il ya eu 5
et sur dame ces trois fous des deux l'a
joué probablement b3 plutôt assez solide
c'est solide
ça va être dur de percer
ce qui peut faire un plan avec à
lieusaint kiev cette cavale et g5
cavens baky à baky qui pouvait se
demander ainsi réussir et à mettre un
peu de pression sur magnus avec les
noirs et il y arrive hein quand même
c'est tout de même à souligner
cailleux 5k relief cette je pense
ouais c'est vraiment on peut on peut
vrai quand on voit ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui on regrette vraiment à hier
qu'il n'ait pas trouvé le dams et 7
ça a été expliqué dans la vidéo de
résumé de ce matin on regrette vraiment
qu'il est qu'il ait raté ce dernier coup
difficile de défense avant l'avant la
récupération des trente minutes
la maxima baky qui fait vraiment une
grosse perf aujourd'hui
hier ils étaient vraiment proches de
l'assaut vers et à un coût
avant quoi qu'il fasse une erreur non
franck magnier je fasse une erreur
alors alors alors alors
nathan le coup de baky
du coup que soit l'issue du match il va
reprendre sa carrière pro note bas qui
m'a complètement l'at-il l'at il jamais
quitté
karlsson qui a regardé la partie d'en
haut pour gêner baky c'est terrible
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué mais
carrément 1,5 bien entendu et peut être
tu vas faire le plan dont on parle et
essayer de mettre le foin 5
ça ce serait cool en vrai
un événement de ouf en vrai que ma qui
gagne cette partie même s'il perdait le
match
bah oui c'est baky aller chercher ce
match ce serait extraordinaire 1
j'ai pas ce qu'il va faire ce complot
est un peu trop tarabiscoté peut-être un
s'est jusque là c'est dur de progresser
avec les noirs
- apparemment davantage un poteau de
l'eau traînant à la position c'est
beaucoup aplanies
reif 8 ouais pourquoi pas
bref pourquoi pas j'ai raison que ce
truc j'ai ça ça m'embête tellement bas
qu'ils perdent
enfin qu'il fasse nul ça me stresse pour
lui demander de me prendre et de france
3 mais les gaffes
je vais déjà montré tout à l'heure mais
franchement il n'y a pas d'obligation de
prendre aux échecs c'est il va juste
bouger la tour malheureusement il a joué
fouache 6 bat qui n'y a pas d'obligation
à la prise quoi
[Musique]
mais ce qui peut tourner
mélanger 5 apprécié les voulu mettre il
aurait pu partir en russie ce peut-être
las rien mais il se prépare peut-être à
faire tous réfutent on est assez
cavalière 3 on sait pas
faites pas le jeu noir qui manque
d'espacé pour répondre au chat c'est
juste qui n'a pas d'idées
la position des blancs est solide on
peut pas l'attaquer donc c'est compliqué
tarifs 7 et j'ai ce à quoi elle ça peut
être une option
après ça donne la case f5 il faudra bien
tenté quelque chose un jour il faudra
bien tenté quelque chose d'un jour
dupouy férois h 2
tellement dur de trouver une idée je me
répète mais c'est complexe
c'est très complexe sont agglutinés à l
aller le roi est mise à part ce micro
point faible en quatre les blancs n'ont
pas de problème et il est très dur à 10
très difficile à attaquer puisqu'ils ont
le bon goût
donc le move est fou c'est le foot blanc
qui peut taper les pions noirs s'est
trouvé un plan trouver un plan pour
mettre la pression et du rhin après il
va falloir tenter des choses c'est un
peu suicidaire comme la mef 16 g 5 g 4
ça doit pas être le plus fort mais au
moins on tente quelque chose de toute
façon il faut tenter un il faut tenter
sinon dans tous les cas on a perdu
si on tente pas dans tous les cas on a
perdu
c'est pas du pion isolé alors déjà c'est
pas la structure classique du pur isolé
mais là c'est contrebalancé par le pion
arriérés part et par le bon bout
le mauvais fond ce que je viens
d'expliquer
il ya il ya un problème des deux côtés
il n'y a pas de rupture en fait
jaurès 40 minutes puis il y aura le
rajout de temps
car c'est un jeu blanc a réussi renfermé
va faire jouer une pièce similaire chez
l'adversaire c'est impressionnant voilà
il est pas mieux car ça n'en faut pas
non plus invités à inventer de la f1 car
la scène il n'a pas pris l'avantagé dans
cette partie n'est pas en train de
donner une leçon à baky un bien là mais
mais il est solide et on trouve pas on
trouve pas comment percer il est reparti
on sait si je veux qu avec son cheval
ce qui va et ce qu'il a une idée en tête
ce qu'il a une idée derrière la tête
qu'elle sait si tu vois pas trop où il
veut en venir
riscle enlever ce cavalier
un petit avantage ne l'a pris à partie
avec les blancs non c'est mieux de
commencer avec les noirs parce que du
coup si tu perds ta les blancs dans la
deuxième donc commencé avec les noirs et
un léger avantage après il ya des
tirages au sort qui qui donne cet
avantage un ou l'autre joueur
c'est pas un énorme avantage mais c'est
plus agréable
on voit bien par exemple dans la partie
de karuïa qui il a perdu la première
avec les noirs oui peut se permettre
d'envoyer un all in avec les blancs et
là il va sûrement égalisé 1
il est une énorme attaque vous me disiez
que champlan d'été gagnants c'était loin
d'être le cas 1
là il va falloir envoyer j'ai cinq
cavaliers qui varient venger 4 qui va
tout envoyer sur le roi car yakine il
peut vraiment y aller aux candidats
ainsi donne tout cardiaque et tabataba
et du coup compte fait d'os ok ça
devrait faire nul et jean-christophe
doute ac contre le fils du gange vie dit
ça devrait faire nul aussi
on voit carricart yakine bas peut mettre
la pression parce qu'il a perdu dans
cette première partie comme je vous le
disais avec avec les pièces noires dont
tu as plus de deux possibilités de jouer
des papes position et des partis à
double tranchant avec les blancs et je
n'aime pas trop champions ne va au
contraire j'ai depuis le début qu'on est
pour shankland à mon cher ami alors bâti
qu'est ce qu'il a derrière la tête ça
magnus de le trouver un
non pas qu'ils aient fait sa game contre
le champion du monde j'ai un petit bug
n'est pas passé loin de la
correctionnelle d'un f3 jouer alors ça
c'est une proposition de nuls tacite
il propose un maquis car a lieu cinq
dames deux quarts lycées sicile en train
de dire à qui tu peux pas progressé je
t'offre la nulle mais ba qui devant une
dizaine de milliers de spectateurs ne va
pas accepter terrible pour magnus
très pleutres là c'est vraiment une
proposition de nuls tacite 1
je sais pas s'il va accepter ou par en
vrai ce serait un peuple autres
d'accepter d'un autre côté ce serait
tellement désespérant cette position à
jouer ça se peut honnêtement qu'en
partie j'accepte ciba qui le fait on
pourra pas le blâmer parce que c'est
tellement dur de trouver même une idée
pour gagner
il a lieu cinq de baky ça peut être la
fin de l'aventuré les amis alors
peut-être qu'il veut voir bas qu'ici
magnus veulent annuler en se disant on
va voir si je dois me de aussi jouer
autre chose
mieux perdre en essayant de faire drôle
sans saveur martin et martine tu fais
comment en fait le poids même là c'est
qu'il ya vraiment pas de plan il ya que
des plans suicide et a pas forcément
envie de te suicider quoi fin c'est à
99,5 chance 99.5 de padt pas gagné
c'est juste silva qui voit pas d'idée
moi j'en vois pas personnellement allé
l'âge où ils tentent tour à fuite qui
refusent terrible pour le saumon il va
tout donné va qui y dont il envoie un
signal à magnus calmement il lui dit je
donnerai tout à l'eba qui est il se lève
bas qui vient de faire un petit signe
il nous a fait un petit signe là-bas qui
très clairement baky qui joue le gars il
va tout donner un il tentera tout
jusqu'au bout le pleutre n'a pas pris là
nul et il n'est pas pu être aujourd'hui
bas qui justement c'est le pleutre a
proposé nul bas qu'il a refusé je cois
magnus
par sûr et le stand alfa échec
exactement d'armes ils font en g3 après
je vois toujours pas comment je le gagne
va peut-être faire cavaler c6 pour
remarquer en d4 il va leur faire flouer
f2
l'acquis qui tente un
allez il faut il faut réussir à mettre
cette pression et magnus plus très clair
dans cette partie
quand même savoir est très bizarre ça
coupe du monde se joue échanges fournis
monde et si le vainqueur de la coupe du
monde n'avait pas son ticket pour les
candidats ouais t'as rien compris aux
règles frérot je dis tout de suite tu
n'as pas compris les règles c'est pas
une coupe du monde c'est un quality
ailleurs pour les candidats mais j'ai
pas le rap et dix mille fois et même si
karastan perdez le titre de champion du
monde il serait quand même qualifiés aux
candidats c'est fait exprès de par le
fait que le perdant du match
championnats du monde à une place
directe aux candidats en fait cette
éventualité est prévu justement pour que
les les joueurs qualifiés ne joue pas
les qualifs et ailleurs c'est terrible
il n'a pas compris les règles qui
revient on sait s'il va refaire foot
c'est fou et f2 c'est pour ça qu'il a
écrit walker partout cc c'est une info
ce une appellation tronquée on l'a déjà
dit mille fois en fait c'est pas un
moment d c'est pas possible de ne pas le
comprendre quoi c'est terrible a forcé
c'est incroyable de ne pas le comprendre
allez
des commentateurs c'est ton rôle d
expliquer les gens ne comprennent pas tu
peux te remettre en question russie dans
les bons fin ça va partir c'est vraiment
n'importe quoi
non ce n'est pas une question de band of
mais des fois c'est un peu un peu
désespérant de voir des gens après sont
un peu aigri chez eux jeu pourra
remarquer un peu aussi comprendre
allez aujourd'hui je vais être gentil et
je vais comprendre que voilà les gens
n'ont pas forcément des vies marrante et
qu'ils ont une certaine aigreur
ça peut se comprendre ça peut se
comprendre et donc il veut aller embêter
embêter les autres je peux je peux le
comprendre
non aujourd'hui on va dire que je suis
je suis je suis apaisé
je suis apaisé les gens et je comprends
que l'on peut on n'a pas tous une vie
facile on est on est pas tous a pas tous
heureux naturellement et je peux
comprendre qu'il ya des gens qui voient
là et steve jobs de haine et de
méchanceté en eux quoi et cette envie de
te faire chier les autres ça peut se
comprendre
je suis apaisé dents cariées c6
allez on va envoyer carey les andes et
quattro peut-être je pense qu'il va
refaire fief de ses traits plus être un
côté carl scène
dans le cas
denquin
il va refaire fleuve dont je sais pas
comment mais j'arrive toujours pas à
trouver une idée
qui sait si ce qui va partir ce qui va
repartir et on va se retrouver bloqué au
point de départ sa voix ample tu
comprends il faut totalement consentie
aujourd'hui j'aurais fait comme 400
j'aurais tenté de faire nul 1-1 ce
qu'alpha 0 gagnant cette position contre
carlos and we forcément un
enfin quoique non pas sur mon vrai pas
sûr mais après le redis c'est toujours
compliqué parce que tu fais une erreur
ou quoi
non car la scène il est très pragmatique
et il joue pour se qualifier il joue pas
pour les poings nommés c'est ce que
j'attendais avant le avant la partie
jusqu'au renvoi repris reçues parfois f2
tempo enfin ce serait peut être un fief
de mais peut-être que baky vadam six
dames 5
ok
ok on va voir on va voir comment ça
évolue tour f1 il est des quatre dames
détroit ça je pense ça va avoir lieu
surtout reprend dame prend dame prend il
ya des six qui tombe une tour huit
retours et tourer et on en est toujours
au même point
allez on est toujours au même point on
arrive pas on n'arrive pas à créer de
menace c'est du rhin
ici là
alors viens à 8 avec la tour ouais c'est
juste que tu arrives pas tu arrives pas
défaire 1
complexe
il va remettre la tour en 1 en fait têtu
tu bloques je suis pas comment il peut
faire
c'est tellement difficile
je
j'essaye vraiment de trouver de se
trouver une idée quoi c'est juste de
trouver une idée je n'arrive pas parce
que vraiment en liga avec g5 h4 c'est du
suicide
les seules idées qui permettent de
tenter une progression c'est du suicide
ça laisse trop de cases s'affaiblit trop
peut-être essayer de jouer à 6 bessengue
numérique soit y
c'est peut-être la seule chance d'un peu
progrès progressé à 6 baies 5 des katas
5 à 4 mètres une tour en a huit essayer
de rentrer par là serait le plan à
mettre en place peut-être le moins
suicidaire
ça doit pas passer mais eux
on pratique il bien que le kava l'ouest
renaître le cavalier angers 5 mai le
temps qu'on fasse ça il y aura des
problèmes sur des six c'est loin
bon
souvent et solide pour y réfléchir il a
fait quoi il a joué un coup il a joué
quoi mettre le foin 5 peut-être aidé à
me 6 g6 fou g7 ou aux 5 sachant j'ai
encore une pièce mais c'est peut-être
notre pire pièce c'est pas si idiot et
pourquoi pas essayer en tout cas un bon
là d'un réussissons peut pas ignorer
crise et 7 pour le moment c'est pas si
simple à mettre en place
5 pourquoi pas sa perte du matériel
immédiatement
ma venue ici c'est là qu'il est trop
solide qui a rien à faire ils se lèvent
y voit qu'il ya pas vraiment de
possibilités pour etienne
peut-être que ben qui devrait lui faire
un plaquage cathédrale c'est peut-être
la seule chance de le battre en dehors
de l'échiquier terrible peut-être qu'il
va falloir qu'ils élargissent le combat
sur l'échiquier il n'y arrivera
peut-être pas mais un plaquage bien
senties du président par être la
dernière chance malheureusement c'est
légal et je sais pas si c'est interdit
par le règlement d'ailleurs comme jamais
dit moi je suis déjà pris un gros coup
de pied avec hématome pendant une partie
de la part de mon adversaire alors beat
n'avait rien dit du coup je sais pas ce
qui est écrit dans le règlement tient
verser intéressant c'est une question
aux arbitres gens réellement hors troll
vu que dans les échecs quand il ya des
trous dans les règlements ils sont ils
sont utilisés par les joueurs est ce que
j'en suis ton camp physiquement
l'adversaire il ya un truc qui écrit que
tu prends forfait genre est ce que c'est
une c'est écrit dans le règlement comme
moi ça m'est déjà arrivé qui s'était
rien passé sur mon adversaire avec la
même logique que karlsson qui joue la
coupe du monde est-ce que théoriquement
ce serait c'est prévu que si tu t'en
vient aux mains avec l'adversaire était
disqualifié
logiquement ça doit être interdit ça
doit être écrit dans le règlement ce
serait complètement logique mais juste
par curiosité ce qu'est ce qu'ils ont et
ce qui est ce qu'ils ont mis ou pas les
règlements des chèques sont les pires
tech jamais écrit on sent on a remarqué
à maximilien d'allemagne ouais vraiment
en fait c'est mon adversaire sous la
table qui m'avait mis un gros coup de
pied monstrueux j'avais juste 11 ans 10
ou 11 ans et j'avais eu un hématome un
hématome au tibia
j'étais vraiment pas bien je pensais
peut-être avoir une fracture mais
l'arbitré avait pas donné n'avait pas
donné de pénalité et j'avais perdu la
partie peut-être en 15 20 minutes
tellement j'avais mal en fait c'est
j'étais pas loin de faire un malaise
enfin c'est quand vous prenez un gros
coup et que si vous avez vraiment mal
vous n'êtes plus très bien volontaire ça
c'est pas la question qui sera
volontaire ou pas à la imaginons qu bas
qui involontairement soulève magnus et
lui fasse un plaquage cathédrale de
manière complètement involontaire
puisque est-ce que moi mais dans mon cas
de figure l'arbite n'avait rien dit
les cas j'adore ça je crois 30 30 35
c'est un adulte mais ce que est ce que
le règlement le prévoit enfin sans tact
en cas d'agression physique aurait
également craint que tout comportement
qui serait à dire ça peut être
sanctionné ok mais ça veut dire que
c'est à l'appréciation de l'arbitré dans
ces cas là la s'était passé parce qu'en
fait mon adversaire avec glissé de sa
chaise et dans la glissade m'avait
balance un énorme coup de pied mais
j'avais vraiment un gros hématome
je me rappelle plus si jamais je crois
que c'est aller chez le médecin après
pour pour vérifier donc est ce que la
siba qui fait pareil en fait il met un
poing américain au bout de son pied et
bon ben pas de chance quoi il n'est pas
fait exprès quoi est ce que je serai
autorisé ou pas dans les charges des
chances quoi bon après c'est du troll un
bien évident parce que c'est c'est un
troll par rapport au rapport à ce qui
m'était arrivé moi évidemment ça ne se
passera pas dans cette partie et a fait
exprès 10 et je sais pas s'il a fait
exprès décès ou pas mais bon c'est quand
même un comportement
[Musique]
enfin mettre en danger l'intégrité
physique de son adversaire un
comportement qui pourrait mener à aa à
une élimination à mon avis il ya une
disqualification la partie
donc à utiliser un service mission est
de père murphy 10 qualified ok mais il
n'y a pas vraiment de on sait pas
exactement ce que c'est quoi une
agression caractérisée c'est fini stable
sur la public dont façon ces exclusions
un truc pas fait exprès c'est le
règlement ait larbi qui devrait gérer et
jugé au caire
distraire dérangère cinq soirées ciba
qui fait réclamations ils ont que magnus
conti reste devant sa table avec son
masque qui gêne il le gène en revenant
est ce qu'on peut avoir une chance ou
pas on cherche des idées on charge les
plans les gars je cherche
idée pour gagner un on lit les
règlements a maintenant
en face kevin moi je vous laisse y
viennent concept ibe mc trx martic ce mc
fly à plomb sur l'échiquier on va
chercher la faille juridique et c'est ça
un vote plus le choix
en tout cas pour pour l'avoir déjà
expérimenté du mauvais côté la glissade
coup de pied violent sous la table pas
sain
on avait peut-être le test pcr ou
équipe-type aussi alléchant cloud c'est
finir vous me disais qu'il était
complètement gagnant hayat enfants g73
projet cette cavale et g4 et d'un match
6/4 a10 a6 a7 armina de quadrillage 7
d'arâches 6,3 g 8 food et 3sat apithy
puis tour g1 et gh1 relief si ça allait
d'un rêve de b6 faudrait trouver une
idée
tout cas car yakine se présente un gagne
de la plus belle des manières avec les
blancs
donc en 4 c'est quoi le problème c'est
qu'ils perdent et 6 à la fin
vb6 peut-être qu'il veut maintenant
après ton point 14.4 2.4 fou prend des
six plus avoir ces cinq en l'air
eva qui parle qui séparait de
l'échiquier
je sais pas je sais pas comment qu'est
ce qui va nous préparer bas qui en tout
cas ils continuent à la joue et elle va
elle va durer longtemps cette partie
après magnus n'est pas vacciné contre
les erreurs peut-être contre le coc vide
mais pas contre les gaffes peut toujours
arriver une erreur à aux échecs
vous savez c'est rare ici et main à ce
niveau là mais on est là
ce serait beau que ba qui reviennent
avec une tronçonneuse en disant au cas
où je vais couper du bois et qui
l'allument
mais saad et concentrerait peut-être son
adversaire qui furent et moi je récupère
les idées du chat à on ne sait pas
que ce soit maxime qui viennent en fait
maxime il pourrait venir déranger
pourrait venir un peu tousser éternuer
devant devant la table ça pourrait faire
la diff
quelque chose vraiment faire quelque
chose des amis ou des idées qu'à magnus
ici salsoul ça se voit que ça le souffle
que ba qui joue il est vrai qu'il ya pas
d'idée il ya un mince espoir
ba qui s'emmerdent part il varie pas
refaire ses livraisons il vient avec des
échiquiers et il vient avec des livres
et il remplit les colis un au moins pas
obligé de trouver un plan de gains mais
il perd pas de temps chef d'entreprise
avant tout ça ça peut être une idée un
chef d'entreprise avant tout
et jouer nue je pense pas que tu es le
droit à ma t on puisque tu as une tenue
correcte exigée
je pense pas que je puisse jouer nue
tu rentre même pas vrai non non non je
pense que tu rentres pas après tu peux
tenter te déshabiller pendant la partie
mais à mon avis en arbitres qui vient
qui vient arrêtez ça tout de suite être
maître forfait
se laver pendant trois mois ça m'est
arrivé de jouer contre des joueurs qui à
mon avis ne s'était pas lavé depuis
plusieurs jours voire semaines
c'est vrai que c'est très dérangeant
plusieurs jours ça m'est arrivé de jouer
contre des joueurs franchement à l'odeur
c'était des c'est est dérangeant c'est
ça m'est arrivé plusieurs fois ça ça
c'est vraiment un avantage pour le
joueur en question
vrai que c'est une strate malsain pains
ouais non bas qui là est peut-être parti
envoyer des colis 1 il se développe à
l'international
bon ben et 6 le mans pls
c'est quoi sur faut pas prendre le 4
parce qu on perdait on perd des paires
d'yeux des 6 à la fin de tête ils
veulent prendre maintenant
on va voir ce qui faire
c'est un pion a de toute façon vrai mais
bon c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il ya peut-être une heure et
demie c'est que même si on gagne 4 elle
va pas être gagnante en corse qui avions
des six qui savent pas grand chose mais
au moins on fait des progrès peut-être
qu'après on met le fond au 5 et petit à
petit on progresse en tout cas on n'a
aucune chance
ça peut peut-être le faire hein on va
voir pour le moment dans une position
d'attenté entre guillemets ou baky
réussi à empêcher que magnus plus fort
cela nul
et petit à petit chaque coup il laisse
une possibilité à magnus de gaffer quoi
c'est tout
la partie de carrière qui abat oui bon
ça c'est vrai que ça le chat ya pas
compris grand chose à cette partie de
sergei voile je dois l'admettre
parce que c'est vrai que vous avez vous
avez été beaucoup à penser que le
champion était gagnant alors qu'il va
prendre un coup terrible à duda qui a
réussi à faire le plan dont j'avais peur
m lecavalier en b 4 ça peut être
dangereux pour le fils du gange
oui donc on pourra voir doute à karlsson
qui serait une belle demi et fait d'os
fêter ça va travailler ça n'a pas bougé
écart yakine karekin qui va s'imposer
aujourd'hui allez on va retourner sur
baky carlson qui apparemment n'a
toujours pas joué
quand on voit cette partie d'aujourd'hui
on peut tellement déçu de qui n'est pas
trouvée jusqu'au dames c 'est tiers
allez même admis cela il est mécontent
parce que c'est le truc c'est qu'il joue
vraiment pour fermer la pause effet
renouvelé aux échecs c'est dur à faire
même un orfèvre comme comme magnus a du
mal à trouver les coups qu'ils ne le
font pas trop reculé mais bon il est
monstrueux pour le faire mais je pense
qu'il aurait préféré avoir une position
où ils pouvaient avoir un peu de contre
et pressé là bas qui peut lui jouer
pendant longtemps
calkins forte impression en tout cas
ce qui veut jouer mais qui hésitent
encore
ça paraît
magnus en vente une life ouais tant que
ça joue il ya de l'espoir
la 1000 pions h4
l'auto reprend tout reprend dame prend
fou prend ya pas d'un 1er tour dames
reprend
bon
turp a dit d1 c'est toujours pareil j'ai
envie de dire il n'y a toujours pas
d'idée
il va sûrement faire cavalier ou 7 ça
bout bref cette même
bah c'est peut-être jamais
qu'est ce qui peut faire baki qu'est-ce
qu'on peut jouer
et des trois récents avec manu se
rendent pas compte quoi
bon s est bétonné 1
fait qu'elle ait des 3 et que ça passe
ça peut être sympa ray
tellement peu de coups
parce que 5 peut être dangereux ça
dépend ça les change des pièces ce truc
ça peut permettre peut-être de jouer un
peu sur le roi là on n'est pas au moment
de se dire avec les noirs est ce que ça
peut donner un avantage aux blancs ou
pas on est en train de se dire est ce
que on peut éventuellement avoir une
position où il ya moyen de faire une
erreur
peut-être qui peut revenir en c6
c'est d'ailleurs aux 5
9,5 s'échange encore
chanteuse a abandonné ou pas encore ça
va abandonner parce que sur pions prend
dame ya dame g63 cet objet c'est à 3 des
sites en 17 matches
complexe
plex complexe
au cirque selon l'ordi après c'est
logique hein ça protège
complexe complexe assez les parties les
plus difficiles à suivre et à commenter
parce que tu as un joueur qui fait
vraiment de l'antijeu en fait et il a
bien raison de le faire bloc et l'autre
en face tente vraiment tous mes mais
c'est tellement verrouillé
[Musique]
la joue et on reprend 1,4 bas qu'ils
allaient y complexifier un peu le délire
mais il n'a pas dû voir lecavalier 7 qui
fait mal d'alger quatre tours prend dame
prend et dames f7 qui va le forcer à
rentrer dans cette finale et là il
n'aura plus aucune chance de gain
malheureusement baki
ouais ça il a raté il a dû regarder ton
tour prendra me prends un truc c'est que
c'est difficile des fois quand tu dois
penser que offensif il a dû voir savoir
cavaliers f5 et désire je veux un peu
joué j'ai trois fous c'est un et je vais
tenter foulée de foot et 4 et j'ai un
peu de j'ai peut-être un peu de jeu mais
amel a malheureusement tout reprendre
quatre cavaliers set et ça va être
terrible
si magnus là après ça arrive de rater
genre de choses parce que ton adversaire
temporis tellement en phase et toi tu
dois tellement fort c'est que tu oublie
un peu les coups en contre
donc je chante landes qui devrait
s'incliner 1 l'asse vraiment matin par
able pourrait retrouver sergueï au
départage demain je pense qu'il va
battre vie dit perso et tabataba et ça
va faire nul hein je vois pas du tout le
joueur iranien perdre cette finale on
devrait avoir deux des partages demain
feydeau cf tabataba et et kara yaqing
contre lâchant clash entre cantons
faveau si on voit des petits champs kla
s'est fait défoncer dans fable
aujourd'hui lâche encore il a rien
compris non chanté à la chanteuse qui
est issu
est ce que ma nièce va trouver le
cavalier 7 ou pas mais ça pourrait faire
une belle demi 1 contre duda et j'ai
peur pour pour jean-christophe qu'ils ne
souffrent dans les ouvertures et
j'aimerais bien que ce soit si si on est
sur un duel car le cndd ou d'axway
jean-christophe qu'ils y aillent
histoire que la compétition n'est pas
été trop dénaturer et l'équité sportive
pas trop dénaturer par la présence de
magnus
il a joué cavalier 7 ouais ouais bien
sûr s'est trouvé en fait c'est pas si
facile à voir en partie vu le la
physionomie à la psychologie de la
partie mais évidemment ça fait mal et
cette partie peut durer longtemps
maintenant mais pas pour la nulle mais
pour la victoire de manu ce qui peut
décider d'aller chercher les points
l'eau terrill baky qui va devoir
défendre maintenant
magnus parisot revient à projets aux
rebelles pour revenir même si gagnes tu
sais peut même jouer les candidats ont
vu le trou qui a dans le règlement on ne
sait pas un drame si leur dire hey mais
ça change rien c'est tout reprend 4,2 me
prendre quatre dames vii ça la position
vous allez la voir
il faut ici va falloir faire dame 6 on
va échanger les dames il rend fou prend
des six
le problème de cette finale c'est qu'on
a les pions sur noir et qui va faire
fougue et huit fois cette les pions sont
sur noir donc le fou peut les attaquer
alors que les pions là sont sur blanc
ils sont difficiles à attaquer donc
c'est un clair avantage blanc après
allez peut-être nul la finale il va
faire qui est des cinq fauves et 8 et ça
va être chaud
huit fois f4 échanges nuls ok mais qui a
rallié ses huit avaient lieu deux qui a
valu à cette querelle et c'est un
cavalier c8 car il ya deux cas les pays
si ce qui est assez inquiet des c'est
toi qui as valet prend b3 mais ici on
peut peut-être faire b 4 puis on prend
on arrive à avant avec hal et blanc
c'est dangereux ces trucs avec un temps
de retard
on a un peu en retard
terrible pour etienne mais il aura
refusé la nullité de tout mais c'est
souvent ce qu'ils arrivent dans ces cas
de figure car il y avait trois échecs
dames six mois mais quand tu vas jouer
le lien avec ça il va prendre dans le
droit chemin bas mais froid j'ai deux
dans le droit chemin draw pareil termine
à dos
à s'entendre caquistes en est on sait
qui est qu'accros maintenant au moins
c'est ça la bonne nouvelle il a dû
dévoiler son identité pour éliminer le
président il fallait s'en douter
il s'en fout de son lots et je crois pas
un
terrible terrible terrible pour le prez
magnus cache-t-il parsifal accueillons
pas dans le but de gagner dans l'unique
but de stopper pas qui a bien sûr un
bac es concentré il a compris ce qui
s'était trompé
m
enfin cette enveloppe à 20 jouable mais
vous donner une qualité un tour prendre
sept points sept cavaliers f5 et la tour
par un
un complot du kaki ce temps
je suis content pour pas qui à ce niveau
et de l'autre je vais au pieu dommage
car le 100 m après wii party pas parler
dès le début on y fait que ça fausser la
compétition et l'équité du tournoi ça se
confirme malheureusement avec avec un
joueur français après c'est comme ça les
règles sont faites ainsi faut les
accepter
terrible
ça te reste car c'est seulement depuis
dix ans atteignait plutôt non c'est
plutôt cool
après après je trouve que c'est dommage
qu'ils aient aussi peu de match pour le
titre de champion du monde se faire une
fois tous les deux ans mais en soi
magnus c'est clairement est de loin le
meilleur joueur de monde depuis une
dizaine d'années un là dessus il ya pas
de doute un juste moi j'aimerais que le
champion du monde un petit peu moins de
privilèges
disons que d'être qualifiés directement
pour le match championnat nîmes ont déjà
c'est une chose mais en plus il ya des
matches que une fois tous les deux ans
donc c'est terrible
il devrait faire le match tous les ans
mais je pense
dans le 6ème ça va être le coup là bas
qui abat qui a compris qu'il pouvait
plus gagner
tous les ans sort un peu plus dans l'air
du temps après les saisons se
ressembleraient beaucoup c'est toujours
sympa tu ahmad championnat du monde 1 il
a pris en 7 bat qui ce qu'ils pensent sa
seule chance pour julien je pense que
leïla il a perdu en lucidité le bas qui
il a perdu en lucidité baky cavaliers f5
c'est pas un crack
je sais pas un peu pas blesser un
craquage c'est juste que voilà il veut
maintenir le rêve si c'est pour défendre
pendant des plombes une position qui n'a
aucune chance de gagner à être veut
continuer à jouer pour quelque chose
c'est un dernier baroud d'honneur c'est
ça dans sa dernière chance jusqu'au bout
la finale
c'est juste un truc lyon est pénible à
défendre ça doit le saouler il préfère
tenter comme ça et quitte à perdre
autant perdre avec les armes à la main
surtout qu'il est peut-être pas perdre
jacques temps prend 1,7 temps pour un
set est-ce que ça père fou 3 d'un f3 kg
trois dames projet un rush trois dames
f5
c'est ce qu'a calculé bac y allez un
petit piège
allez un petit piège
est ce que ça peut pas
c'est la mine à tours 2-1 stehlik ou
qu'on avait vu
tente le tout pour le tout
on voit tout un magnus évidemment
l aie a plus trop de coups en fait
suite
complexe
il ya une qualité de moins
attentes à 6 v5 a probablement mais bon
là c'est un peu lui faire flouer 44.63
prend 1,6
elles n'ont pas de monde on gagne 5 g
iii et à l'étranger trois peut-être mais
je sais pas mais c'est dur car yakine
essais signés avec ce joli maths et de
cf tabataba et ça va petit à petit vers
la drau est d'avis dit d'avis dit c'est
chaud en fait parce que vie dit il veut
cbc 4 essayer de faire la course
donc c'est très chaud cavaliers trois
prix et jk tu rates en prendre trois
jean pierre kary kinder matin non on va
peut-être faire la partie de baky quand
même ils vont c'est pas dit qu'on ait le
temps d'analyser une partie complexe
comme ça faut voir parce qu'il ya là
cette battle ce soir on fait beaucoup de
choses on n'a pas toujours le temps de
faire ce qu'on souhaite
cette bataille c'est une formalité
restera tout à leur sélection vers 19h30
que va faire bac et six à tenter
d'amener quatre peut-être dame g4 pour
ce qui est des projets 3 à 7 bateaux
l'inventeur
ça commence à faire son rôle web et a
bien raison maintenant il va essayer de
la gagner en magnus
dames g41 phare d'un f3
ouais
complexe
complexe pour le prez
très complexe
j'ai plus quoi vous dire en fait ce qui
se passe rien il peut rien se passer
quoi ça fait ça fait 3 heures qui se
passe rien qui peut rien se passer
sa tête est encore le cas pendant une
heure et demie et jeu honnêtement je
sais plus quoi vous dire à force 1 là on
est dans un moment où ça devient
difficile de meubler sur ma chaîne perso
c'est plus facile dans ces cas là je
serais parti envoyé en vie dessous
quelque chose parce que l'acea
c'est juste triste à regarder en fait là
il ya vraiment plus aucune chance
là on est plus sûr du 1 % on est sur du
0,05 pour cent se dirigent mais qu est
ce qui est arrivé
grosse défense enfin partie très solide
de magnus s'est pas passé grand-chose et
baky qui force le gain mais ça va pas
passer at on se fait chier ben ouais un
petit peu c'est dur pour vite dit ça va
taper ça fait à ferdinand vrai la
journée va la partie intéressante c'est
vrai surtout être celle là en fait je
pense doute à vie dit et karine qui a
déjà battu shankland
on innove car vrai on est la fibre
soutenir le prez non mais c'est vraiment
dommage que kylie kylie perdu hier en
fait parce que c'est
c'est hier qu'il a un petit peu
hypothéqué ses chances aujourd'hui donne
tout et yari font plus une bonne partie
à un couperet à un coup près il était
encore dedans quoi c'est quoi ta chaine
perso ça doit être youtube.com cela jeu
vidéo échec
ça c'est ma chaîne youtube perso et et
twitch et twitch point tv slash
bitstream dur à lasseube battle ce soir
d'ailleurs j'ai préparé une nouvelle
vidéo sur orbite rimes faciles qui
sortira ce week end sur les jo depuis on
compte la tour si tiéné mais tu vas
quand même ce que les prochains tours à
la demi finale c'est sûr parce que je
m'étais mis d'accord sur les
demi-finales la finale ça dépendra si à
une place pour les candidats en jeu ou
pas match pour la troisième place ou pas
en fait ça battles et un tournoi où les
seuls jeux vous contrôlez celle d'une
autre chaîne ouh là là ça jouer thème
pour ou là qu'est donc là c'est c1 dames
forcé pour visite et tour à 7
il faut savoir sir matt ou pas on leur
dit qu'ils ahmad donc on va lui faire
confiance
ouais ça va gagner la dame et ça va être
gagnant visite va très probablement
s'incliner tabataba et contre fait d'os
ça va faire nul et bas qui va se faire
éliminer alors il ya quoi comme cookies
et des quatre tournois
en se battant pour une chance où l'on se
bat alfred c'est vrai
d'activation éliminé vie dit fécales et
des quatre tours d un ce que baky peu le
flag non fasciste c'est bien la tronche
red and détroit et là on peut vraiment
pas créé de menaçant ce fois çi sort a
été la mauvaise pièce des noirs toute la
partie après silva qui n'avait rien
forcer ça aurait fait nul 1 il ne perd
que parce qu'ils forcent bas qui il
reste encore cinq coups avant le avant
le rajout de temps et magnus qui
affronterait duda ça va être une belle
demi-finale à titre perso comme je
disais je ferai pour duda quand même si
c'est antisportif indifférent et quand
même sur ce tournoi
ouais mais bon julien enfin il est
champion du monde n'a il joue très bien
baky d'avoir tour eiffe un fou ou trois
quelque chose comme ça attention parce
que ça va rentrer en f7 ça risque de
faire mal
et si bien qu il pourra y pourra s'en
vouloir un que mc magnus et participer
parce qu'il va peut-être même pas se
qualifier au grand prix fidh
ce qui ne veut pas se qualifier alé lô
et le grand suisse ça va vraiment être
une loterie ça tombe très difficile et
un joueur comme messi piano du coup en
étant en ayant été dans le mauvais côté
du tableau pourrait ne même pas jouer
les grand prix fina alors que c'est un
jeune qui pourrait théoriquement aller
aux candidats l'a2 au delà de baky qui
n'est pas vraiment du bon côté de
l'équité sportive mais même chose pour
ici piankov surtout qu'est si bien qu il
est passé vraiment proche d'éliminer
magnus
donc à vrai dire si un joueur qui doit
vraiment rage et de la présence de
magnus est ici pinko mais d'un autre
côté ils étaient contents de le jouer
donc l'un dans l'autre ça va
limite on ne peut pas en vouloir à
cassen on peut revoir instruction les
règlements c'est ce que c'est ce que ce
ce que je dis depuis depuis quelques
jours mais tu as dit d'accord avec toi
c'est pas c'est enfin c'est sur les
raies qui sont mal faites après certains
ouvrir la classe de ne pas participer
pour garder l'esprit de la règle entre
guillemets car le sel ne veut vraiment
vraiment gagner ça a pressé c'est son
problème c'est pas c'est pas lui c'est
pas son problème à lui le problème ceux
qui font qu'ils font les règles de
preuve ne vient pas plutôt de
l'appellation world cup semble devoir la
jouer la gagne et de la gagner après
martigues mcfly dans le dans les échecs
entre guillemets tout le monde sait que
cette world cup n'est pas une vraie
world cup en vrai on va pas me dire que
tout le monde est au courant que c'est
passé pas voir que l'appellation est
tronqué c'est pas magnus qu'on va
apprendre ça hein on sait très bien que
les joueurs qui sont qualifiés au cargö
candidats ne la joue pas cette world cup
c'est comme ça hein
je sais bien
km 3 voilà c'est dit
abbas et qualité de - oui oui c'est fini
c'est à dire que c'est un truc est-ce
que tu connais l'histoire de la coupe du
monde chris mire parce que tu sais
pourquoi s'appelle coupe du monde ça en
fait la question c'est ce que tu sais
d'où vient cette compétition pourquoi
elle existe
moi j'ai déjà expliqué plusieurs fois
mais est pourquoi elle s'appelle comme
ça ferait quand le sang ne sachant pas
ça pose un problème
les varois g3 et dames quatre terribles
arctic sea mais quand on entend ses plus
dignes et la world cup à cause du format
sans devient un des rares objectif de
magnus barème et du coup y'a pas les
meilleurs qui participent ils manquent
il manque le numéro 2 et numéro 3
clairement les pots et ding dans ce
format là qui aurait été très dangereux
qui sont très très dangereux pour magnus
il manque aussi radjabov qui est très
dangereux dans ces formats là et donc vu
que les autres il participe à bassa peu
pain si c'était vraiment un titre de
champion du monde qui était donné à la
fin bien évidemment n'est pas
participeraient il manque wesley aussi
qui n'est pas venue mais si c'était
vraiment et qui est vraiment très fort
dans ce format là pour la paix nous et
cela et qui serait venu si c'était
vraiment une coupe du monde en fait
s'ils avaient un titre de champion du
monde à la clé évidemment quand ils
manquent
il manque vraiment les numéros 2 3 4 et
5 du format évidemment c'est on sait où
aller de la phase de penser que c'est
que c'est l'équivalent d'un titre de
champion du monde jason roy g3 et là
c'est vraiment plié c'est vraiment plier
pour notre baky qui a abandonné c'est
terminé le président qui se sera bien
battu qui aura tout tenté il ya un peu
trop forcé il finit par perdre
magnus qui aura une bonne stratégie
l'aller c'est baky prendre l'initiative
et la responsabilité de la partie pour
pour mieux le contrer stratégie loi
blain honnêtement
au tournant de bas qui en fait des
citations à baky pour son tournoi qui a
fait un beau tournoi qui est tombé sur
plus fort que lui il est il et il a
perdu les armes à la main il a tout
donné jusqu'au bout il s'arrête en quart
de finale il s'est quand même qualifié
pour pour les grands prix fidh
car ça nous inquiète vraiment monstrueux
toute façon il est il sera favori de son
match contre les pots mais ce sera
intéressant à ce match championnat du
monde n'est pas ok a progressé aussi de
son côté va faire avant de se quitter
juste un petit saut de puce sur les
autres partis tout va l'emporter c'est
sûr donc lui il ira en demi finale
contre carl scène ce sera une belle
affiche et tabataba et feydeau seief ça
devrait faire nul mais fait dos avec une
belle technique rouscoff peut tenter de
la gagner donc bas qui jouera jouera les
grands brief idée nous on se retrouve ce
soir sur les coups de 19h 19h30 pour la
sélection et lasseube battle à 20 heures
et entre temps je vais aller faire une
petite sieste je vous remercie tous
d'avoir suivi on va accompagner le
parcours des français on se retrouvera
demain pour une partie des départage et
après dimanche pour les demi finales à
tout à l'heure les